Four,
three,
two,
one.
Boom.
We've done thousand.
What,
how many podcasts?
1,000.
One hundred and 16.
Steven Tyler was the only man to bring a
crystal ball here the first because you
got to bring it with you when you come.
Do you bring that everywhere?
Yeah,
I'll bring it with me to Maui.
I'll bring it with me to,
to uh,
Europe.
Yeah.
What is it?
It's just I'm into Chrysalis are just,
it's ready.
It's got a beautiful occlusion and when
you get the light just right on it.
Just like me on stage at night when the
night is jess,
right?
You know what I'm saying?
Dude,
you look fucking fantastic for 70.
Can I just tell you I thought you were
70.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
You look really good and it's amazing.
It really does.
And I walk around like this and wonder
why everybody's fucking taking pictures
and busting my chops.
Walking through the airport.
I actually have a tee shirt that says go
fuck yourself because you're walking
with a dog and you're walking with a
girl and they come over and want to stop
and take a Selfie song,
but thank you.
Thank you for that.
Is that what it is?
Well,
I don't know.
I spent 30 years of it on drugs and
drunk.
So maybe the crystal helped you?
I think so.
I say something.
Yeah.
How long have you been carrying that
thing around?
I don't.
It's it lives in my house.
I have one.
I do keep in my pocket.
We do is not here today.
Oh,
what is that?
He preached Switchblade,
Jesus Christ.
Joe Perry and I got a thing,
you know,
we switched places.
We just collect knives,
man.
We're just.
Well,
you know,
I'm such a country boy.
And when I did idol every night when I
walked out on stage and went to bed a
bit,
a bit,
a bit a bit it.
And I'm walking next to j Lo and randy,
my knife was right in my pocket in case
someone just one thing.
No opening my fan mail.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Switch plate to open fan.
It's fun.
It's a cool thing.
Is Fun.
You don't often carry it,
but I,
I thought because I think you're so
fucking cool that I would bring a couple
of cool things from my house,
you know,
I'm just like that.
Oh,
thank you.
I'm one of those guys that want to leave
the house I go to.
I said goodbye house number.
I got a son and three daughters.
Right.
So.
And I know after watching.
What was the,
what was your last triggered that you
got a bunch of kids too and it starts
wearing off on you.
I think it's a beautiful thing.
I think it's a beautiful thing to his
wife and two girls.
I have three girls.
Three daughters.
It will happen to you.
I do too.
Oh yeah.
You're a legit eccentric.
Like there's some people that pretend to
be eccentric.
Heel like a legit one.
I am and I love it.
In fact,
I love me.
It's good to love more than that.
I love us.
I love us too.
I say that all super happy about this.
I'm so fucking excited.
Seriously,
I've got to ask you,
what the fuck do you eat for breakfast?
Um,
how did you get so fucking smart?
Oh,
I'm not that smart.
I just remember things.
Okay.
Because that's the difference.
There's a difference between being smart
and just remembering a lot.
I'm sure you remember.
Yeah.
I'm not that smart.
Well,
remembering things is huge.
It helps.
Certainly helps.
Yeah.
But what is smart,
right?
Smart is like,
can you solve equations?
Can you figure things out that other
people can't figure out?
You know,
things other people don't know.
No,
I just remember shit that smart people
have already figured out.
But you accumulate situations.
It was like Jimi Hendrix experience
experiential.
So if you remember those things over and
over,
you're going to become a wizard.
You're with.
You're so good.
Thank you.
That's,
that's why I watched your show and I
watched the beginning right before you
walked out on stage.
The triggered.
And I'd say two things that came to my
attention was one,
you were talking with your producer,
whoever they said there's your chair.
And by the way,
you bottled waters right there.
We need those guys.
Right?
Oh,
for sure.
And the other thing is you were sitting
on the couch alone reading your notes.
Yeah.
And you show that it's a beautiful
thing.
I can't live without my notes.
I can't.
I fly at such a speed,
such an altitude that I can't remember
what I did yesterday,
but then I have longterm where I go.
Yeah,
that was a three months ago.
But I just thought I would read you a
timeline because I saw you reading your
notes April 15th,
lunch with the kids in Venice.
My daughter lives in Venice.
Hi Chelsea.
That's a long time ago.
Drove to San Diego,
you know,
a month because I don't have good
memory.
Alright.
Drove to San Diego that night.
So you write things down like after you
did them just to solidify them in your
head?
No,
I just came from a whirlwind of press
and Steven Tyler Day and released a
documentary.
The kct did and all this shit happened
and we played the jazz fest in New
Orleans and that happened in the last
two weeks and I just said to amy,
what have,
what have we been doing in the last?
Where have we been?
Right.
So I wrote it down,
drove to San Diego after Venice did a
private show,
flew to Orlando that night.
Right.
Okay.
Private Gig with David Foster,
Katy Perry,
peer from idle.
This girl was so sweet.
I'm rehearse with the band.
Uh,
and during the break from the band,
I was in Disney world.
I rode,
I rode my rollercoaster and I just got
back from Disney world and I wrote your
rollercoaster yesterday so you know,
you've made it when I see the day before
yesterday.
So I'm going through this list and I
went,
wait a minute,
we want.
And it was just a,
you know,
so rode the roller coaster that I had
overdosed her.
That rock and roller coaster.
He's great.
Right?
Two Times it goes up like the ankles
backwards.
Yeah.
Zero to 60 in two point eight seconds.
Pretty Dope.
Yeah.
Sick electromagnetic propulsion dude.
Dude,
what are we doing here?
What are we doing here?
So then I went over to the animal
kingdom and to visit some of my old
girlfriends.
No,
I went through the Avatar ride.
I had to.
Shit I fucking shit.
Is that Avatar ride intense?
The one when you get on the bike,
you're flying on the dragon virtual
reality.
That's the greatest ride of all time.
The greatest,
I think it's called flights of passage.
It was what's called,
it might be not.
Avi I've taken.
I just got,
I went to,
just to break here for a second.
I went to Betty Ford eight years ago
because I got fucked up with my foot
stuff and just stuff with your foot
stuff.
Uh,
I had an operation on my foot,
you know,
and I kept the meds right by the bed,
you know what I'm saying?
What'd you get done with my girlfriends?
So they were right there and I thought
five minutes ago when a ticket,
another one.
That's what happens to a lot of people
with those pain pills.
So I checked myself into bay for it,
but while I was there,
they let me out a couple times.
I saw Avatar eight times.
Did you get avatar depression now know
what that is?
No,
no.
I became her,
right?
Oh No.
Not to leave weaver character.
The other one,
right?
Yeah.
The girl and I'm not.
The guy became her and I just watched
her moves and he's pretty dope.
I cannot wait for that to come out.
Yeah,
it's going to come out soon.
Okay.
Then we'll be back in a.
We flew right to New York City after the
show went to see Bruce springsteen's one
off.
I'm probably that night.
How was that?
Sick.
He's so good now.
I got to tell you,
I'm not the biggest bruce springsteen
fan,
but um,
I respect him.
I love his music.
I know we became a phenomenon like 72,
like when we did and sitting there and
watching him be honest and talk to this
crowd and sing songs and play the piano
and talk as truth.
And then he said something like,
um,
he goes,
you know,
there's New Jersey thing with a pregnant
pause,
pregnant pause.
He goes,
I invented that.
And that was it.
He warmed my heart because when someone
says that it was so real and so true.
But Sinatra was from hoboken.
Yeah.
And I'm from yonkers.
Okay.
Or the Bronx,
one of the Bronx.
I was born in New Jersey to new NORC.
Wow.
Fascinating Newark,
New Jersey Trivia.
And right where you were born and they
put an airport.
I think it was already there.
So you lived in the higher end
neighborhood?
Not really.
Okay.
So that night flew,
flew right to New York City after the
show went to see Bruce springsteen.
And I said that redundancy.
And you loved it?
I loved it.
Um,
um,
then I did the next morning,
woke up,
did Harper's bazaar shoot for the cover
with my daughter live,
Keith Richards,
daughters were there,
all that stuff.
After I hung out with Lenny Kravitz,
had a nice couple of slices with lenny.
My Bro flew to muscle shoals right after
that and recorded the song with Nuno
Betancourt.
Sick as fuck.
So good.
That was.
That was three days of this.
This is a hell of a timeline you got
going on here.
Yeah,
the and that was the next day.
I went right to recalls place who passed
away like three months ago and his son,
Rodney Hall works the place.
It's called fame studios and and I sat
in a room.
He took me all over the place and I
walked in to like the demo room where
you could smell the oxides off the tape.
Wow.
We'd like Percy sledge demo.
Wait,
know that first shit,
the first stuff or Wilson picket and I'm
sitting in the room with him and I'm
telling you,
man,
I started to cry.
I cried.
I welled up three times.
Wow.
Just to be in the room.
I'm standing doing the vocals to brown
sugar.
Right?
We're a little Richard's right where he
sang.
I see a picture on the wall of him
standing right there.
He's all in muscle shoals muscle shows.
Did you see that documentary?
I did.
I watched the documentary,
first of all,
I said,
I'm in.
What is it about that place?
How did that place?
Here's what it is.
It's the vibes.
If you're into vibes,
yeah,
if you're into living,
if you're into fueling live,
you can always feel sad when your mom
dies,
but you got to amp that up.
You've got to feel good when bad things
are going now you've got to thank God
when bad things are going.
Are you going to be into crystals?
Love you,
love your girlfriend.
Try to be happy to.
I find the positivity and negativity,
and then when you're listening to music
and your very favorite thing in your
close your eyes,
that's vibes.
That's something you can't even talk
about.
Really.
It's how you feel personally.
Whatever you've been through in your
life,
those vibes of those songs.
Wilson picket,
little Richard.
I mean the allman brothers started
there,
right?
So when you listen to the allman
brothers,
you,
you're in the room were Greg said to his
brother,
let's do this song.
So do you think it is?
Because all those talented people
perform there and they,
they're like,
let it soak into the building.
Is that what it is?
Because there's,
there's places that do have like a magic
to them.
I always talk about the comedy store
like that.
The comedy store is a magic to it.
When you're there,
there's something about that place.
So like it feels like great things have
happened that place before you feel it
in the.
Would you feel it in the carpet?
It's just,
it's in the air.
You feel like that was muscle shoals,
is it?
Is it because all those great artists
have performed there and like almost
like the room has a memory of it?
I think so because there's some
scientists that think that things have
memories.
It's,
it's a weird,
impossible to prove idea.
Okay,
well,
when you die,
did you know that you,
that you're on the table,
you die,
and if the table is you're being weighed
as you die,
it goes down a number 27 grams.
Huh?
That's not real.
It's not true.
Now.
One of the things that people would say,
sure,
yeah.
There's no way of really measuring,
Oh man,
you just burst beloved.
It's just one of those.
Hold on.
It's one of those hippie thing.
It's one of those hippie things that
people love to see.
Sure.
Pretty sure Jamie wants Google it.
I'm pretty sure that's the way I believe
in that.
I do too.
So I walked in the room and like,
check this out.
So if one of my favorite Hendrick
Hendrix songs.
Well are you an,
are you experienced right?
Not necessarily stone,
but beautiful.
Meanwhile you walk on stage and go,
fuck me,
these edibles.
I walk in here and go,
fuck me.
I didn't do my nails.
But you use these edibles now.
Used to do all kinds of crazy shit.
What do you mean drugs drug wise?
Oh you fuck.
Yeah,
of course.
Well,
yeah.
when you were being born,
I was walking around New York City with
John Belushi,
knocking on everybody's door to get some
blow.
I mean we were good friends.
We,
it's what you did back then.
I believed that,
uh,
in the spirit of music was,
think of it this way.
Why do you think they call blue spirits?
And when you listen to your favorite
song,
you want to fuck your wife?
Hmm.
I think that spirits in know,
wherever it takes you,
whatever feeling it is,
whatever.
When I went to muscle shoals,
I put my hand on the wood.
I felt the room because I knew that
little Richard's stood right in front of
me.
All I gotta do is close my eyes and go
back in time for a second.
If I,
you know,
I did a song with um,
a roots,
rock reggae,
play that funky music and it was a shit.
See,
I don't have a longterm memory.
Who did that song?
Come on.
Help me play that funky music.
White boy,
you know,
roots rock,
reggae roots,
rock reggae.
Who's up?
Who's the best reggae artists of all
time?
Okay.
Son Calls me up and goes,
you got to do the song.
I go in,
they put in,
they put it on the two inch tape oxide,
the old fashioned two inch tape and I'm
in there ready to sing.
Right?
And um,
they started rolling and I'm listening.
I got,
I got everything turned up and I hear
Bob walked into the studio,
I hear the drummer sit down with a drum
set and this is stool squeaks.
Any farts?
No,
but is he can hear him pick up sticks
you here.
You're the bass player.
Fucking around with his base and talking
to Bob Mun.
What you fucking would you feel how
you're feeling today,
man,
and I'm in the room with Bob Marley.
So what is spirit if that's not it,
I made them play that back again for me
because I just closed my eyes and you're
in the room with Bob Martin.
What is certainly something right?
When you hear a song,
a great song from the past and you get
goose bumps and just feel it inside of
you.
Do something.
You get moved,
but what does it have to do with booze?
I think booze is called spirits because
it puts you in that place.
Tony releases falsely mission and
releases in innovation.
So,
so great truth.
Sarah Misner.
It is,
but is it false or is it just that it
just gets abused?
I think it's not false.
Exactly.
It makes you say things you wish you did
and then you go.
I was lying fucking around.
Well,
you can be in love for a moment,
bitch.
You fucking fuck.
Fuck.
I thought you meant the Nice.
Tell me you've never done blow.
I've never done blow.
Ever now unfortunately drink either.
I drink.
Okay,
cool.
Yeah.
When I was growing up,
my friend's cousin sold blow and I saw
disastrous results and I was scared off
of it when I was very young.
Wow.
Good for them.
I had some friends that as I grew older
and had blow problems so and I never
touched it.
See,
you're one of them and it's your normy
normy in some ways,
but I've done a lot of different things.
Like you said in that last,
that last documentary,
just joking.
You are farthest from the army.
Some people.
It's worth that.
You thought not to do that.
Yeah,
it just seems like one that I would like
too much.
It's one of the reasons why I never
fucked with speed either.
I feel like I'd be like,
now I can get things done if you drink
coffee,
but it's mild coffee doesn't really.
Jack is fucking mile.
This man is just mild.
He what is it?
Kim Chameleon which changes your fucking
skin into another color.
This is a cold brew cold brew coffee,
coffee.
I mean this is really.
Not that.
It's not coffee.
It's called Lucky Jack's nitrile cold
brew coffee.
You might as well just stick this in
your arm.
I don't think so.
Really.
I mean I don't know because I've never
stopped anything like that.
My arm neither have.
I am just saying on that.
It's not that it's,
it's pretty strong actually.
It's probably not like what I make in
the morning is like Kona coffee.
I love Kona.
Carl and I fill that fucker at the top.
It's so dark when you pour it,
you can't see through the stream.
That's when you know you're going on Joe
Rogan and going to spew some shit.
Some real shit.
Oh fuck him.
Hot Lava.
Hot Lava from Kona.
So then.
So we did that.
So we did.
We did branch out with me and Nuno
Betancourt and we got all the players
from way back then the horn section
sections got curls to sing it.
It's just going to be bobby womack sat
in that room and he did.
You know,
I used to love you,
but it's all over now.
So that was that day.
Marvin Gaye.
I'm in this room with all this tape.
So if you're a musician,
you feel the vibes.
If your comedic and you go to the comedy
store,
you feel like you're walking around and
placenta.
Yeah.
There's not a recording spot for
comedians.
You know,
you guys have a bunch of performing
spots,
but you also have recording spots.
We only really have performing spots as
we record in those performance buttons,
but I'm performing.
Yeah,
I mean I go into.
I just had these on last night fixing
the lyrics and when I.
When you have them on,
you're listening to the track.
It's just,
it's something you can't explain.
Nobody understands that and it's akin to
tripping on acid.
It's akin to being drunk and sucking
face with a girl,
making out with her.
It's akin to watching your kids be born.
It's an elevated experience way
elevated,
and if you.
If you buy it and you push the top floor
like I do way past the penthouse bloom,
well I know you do it.
That's why I'm reading this off.
This is a day.
This is a a day.
This is what it was.
A month.
Well,
whatever it is,
it's also.
You've been doing this a long time.
This is like a life where.
I mean the reason why you don't have any
memory,
it's because you've probably filled all
your hard drive space with crazy
experiences.
Well said.
You know,
I have forgotten more than most people
could ever remember.
How could you not wear the.
How the fuck could you remember?
Everything you've ever done.
He'll talk to a farmer about some shit
that happened in the fifties or old.
That was the day that Carol wouldn't
give us milk.
They remember.
It's two things going on here.
I'm surrounded by people that are always
remind me.
That's good too.
You've got a good team.
Yeah,
and sometimes they got to be on,
like live on the tonight show.
This thing I did was with that beautiful
blonde entertainment tonight was I just
watched it back.
I thought that's the best interview I
think I've ever done because she looked
me square in the eye.
She was beautiful.
She asked the right questions and it was
just perfect.
And you got to be on,
in those moments.
Yes.
That's all.
That's what I'm saying.
Me Too.
Do you,
do you miss being not sober sometimes?
Yeah.
I,
um,
I miss a pros and cons that,
that if I do,
I'll wind up doing too much for sure.
For sure.
I can't control it.
It's just the way you are,
just the way I am and I don't want to.
I don't want to push it again because
when I get that way,
my kids don't talk to me.
I get a divorce,
I'm throwing out on my own band.
Right,
right.
Uh,
what else?
I lose everything.
I mean,
it's happened enough times for me to
finally realize,
you know what?
It's not worth it.
You know,
I get it.
You understand?
What I'm saying and I got a lot of
beautiful friends.
I got a beautiful,
um,
bunch of friends,
to keep me in line.
You know,
I got two sponsors,
one on the west coast,
one of the east coast that I call up all
the time ago.
I want to get so fucked up.
Right.
How does that work?
When you call them out,
what do they say?
Don't do it,
Steven.
No,
no,
fuck dude.
I do too,
but I keep it together.
Exactly.
They'll just say,
what else is new?
Did you guys ever talk about it that
way?
Like fat people talk about food they
used to eat?
No,
because we don't do that.
What was it called?
Looking back and take it into the
dinosaur shit.
No do.
But you do.
If you go to like an AA meeting,
they do get up and tell awesome stories.
Oh fuck you getting fucked up.
Right.
See when you get sober,
if you don't,
if you don't continue your aftercare by
going to a couple meetings every now and
then you're going to wind up using
again.
Really,
especially someone like me who watched
Janis Joplin up there.
Okay.
In 1968,
I'm in a high school.
She's got bangles and beads like this
shit on and she's,
she's drinking southern comfort and
she's spitting and using the f word,
smoking cigarettes.
Nobody did that back then.
She was powerful watching her and she's
fucking the power in song.
That's why I covered that on my country
album.
Yeah.
To this day I listen to that song like
at least once every couple months.
Just put that in the headphones.
So you see us,
us.
What songs can do for you.
Well,
when you,
when you grew up in the sixties and what
we did was we experimented,
you know,
I mean if you think about what they tell
us,
Christopher Columbus discovered America
know the bow of his boat was full of
booze and he fucked Queen Elizabeth or
whoever.
She goes,
go,
good boy,
you know.
And she sent him on his way with some
money and said,
bring me back some countries you think.
And by the way,
he wasn't the first person here.
That's what America wants us to believe.
But anyway,
so,
so Christopher Columbus,
he's got that in his head to go to go
check shit out.
Right?
He's drinking,
he's going by the stars at night.
It's kind of like that.
It's like you never took lsds have taken
acid.
Okay.
So then you know what you,
you look out.
We used to take acid in high school and
we would,
we'd go to these.
I'm a ski slopes in the summertime,
right.
Beautiful Green Hills going up and we'd
ride the chairlift stoned as fuck.
And we got our stuff from San Francisco,
from Mosley who I would call him up and
go duty.
More colors,
more colors,
rate to boundless,
going to kill me.
But that's what.
So you understand that?
That's just,
it's like,
you know,
is it fucked up in its drugs?
Yeah.
But you're also,
it's like I'd love to do Iowasca.
I'd love to hear maybe my bucket list
and that's what I'll talk to my sponsor
about.
Hey,
I got this,
uh,
I'm in Maui.
Maybe I've been here too long,
but I'm over.
And Hannah that,
and I saw that you were at Rom Dawson's
place as you were there with my friend
Duncan trussell.
Hell yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Doug had sent me a picture.
You guys together,
do you know?
I went back,
they had a silent auction and I,
I,
you know,
I know Ron Doss,
he's,
you know,
he's beautiful Jewish kid from long
island,
Long Island.
And he became what he did.
Talk about spirituality.
So I'm at the silent auction and I
bought this and that and this and,
and one of these Mellotron type thing
that you squeezebox she squeezed me the
fingers and play it.
And when I left there,
guy comes over and says,
you just bought the first edition of his
book in his own handwriting.
You just bought his.
I forgot what the hell those things
called non accordion,
right?
It's an accordion.
And,
and I got to listen to a two Ram das
talk and sat right in front of him on a
trip.
Yeah,
he's a trip.
I need to meet him before he leaves this
earth.
Yeah,
Dunkin raved about them.
Yep.
So what were you doing there?
Do you,
you obviously have an interest in
psychedelic experiences,
but you are wary about attempting them
at this stage after your sobriety.
What?
I love to trip again.
Yeah,
I would.
Do you think you could do it and you
know,
maybe it's just like you just don't.
Maybe it's getting fucked up.
That's the bad thing.
Like just getting fucked up.
Just getting drunk and coked up and
maybe that's the problem.
Maybe no,
it.
Kindness,
shamanically ceremony.
Maybe it wouldn't be a problem at all.
Here's the deal.
It's all one thing getting fucked up,
shamonic,
whatever.
If you take in drugs and you fucked up,
you fucked up.
It doesn't matter if it's romantic or
not.
If you,
if you get high and that tweaks,
that little thing in my brain that goes
on here.
I go,
remember in your brain for 30 years,
right?
I'm from the sixties,
With the best of them.
I got high and it took them down.
Some of them,
most of them.
You came through it remarkably unscathed
if you think about it.
Yeah.
Thank you God.
It's pretty amazing.
Thank you.
God.
Think about that one.
Yeah.
Think about that.
We could talk for two hours.
About Times I did shit and almost died.
So sure.
You know,
and then I could also tell you how many
times I took shit and wrote things like,
you know,
I'm listening to this guitar lick that
Joe's playing.
He did an interview here with you.
Yeah,
but he didn't tell you how in his
fucking sleepy loop play these riffs.
And I come down the hallway because,
you know,
as I see it,
of course not as ace it,
but as I see it,
we were up in New England and he was
playing at a place and I mowed the lawn,
my,
my parents place.
And I quit my last band and I was
fucking a Lou who saw her.
I was crying.
I was no more bands.
The dream was over.
He drives up in an mg.
We go and he's playing that night.
I swear to God this happened and so we
decided to move down to Boston,
but all in an apartment because I
thought I knew why those bands didn't
make it.
But I knew in my heart did,
if I had a broan abandoned,
like I'm making a keith.
Like the kinks.
Yeah.
David,
you know ray,
any of those bands they had.
They,
you have.
It was two guys that were really tight.
They feed off each other.
The Fed off each other.
Exactly.
So we moved down there.
I got really tight with Joe.
I hear him.
He'd get,
we get so swept.
We were so stoned on bullying.
Boone's farm.
You mean fucking.
I said,
what'd you say?
What'd you say?
Anyway,
but he would play these licks.
It was so fucking for every song you've
ever heard.
Sweet emotion.
Every one of those legs walk this way.
There's 20 that got lost in the ether
ether.
So I went out and bought a little thing
called the tape recorder back then
remember this was 71.
You know,
a lot of shit.
Wasn't no phones,
no cell phones.
So I would record that shit.
And so anyway,
where we're going with this,
that's,
that's what,
that's where these songs came from and
stuff would come out of my head while I
was like sweet white.
Well Fuck,
get me paper,
paper and pen.
I write that shit down suddenly.
Whoops.
On the radio.
So I used that place.
You get,
you go to,
when you eat edibles you have a right.
Some of your routines when you know for
sure.
Well and also check this out.
The best part of it is when I got sober
I started writing even better shit.
I go in a room with four guys and say
we're going into right ahead.
We're going to say in this fucking room
until we do or until we can't stand each
other smell.
And we would leave in seven hours with a
fucking song and a good one and one that
would live way past all those.
Check that shooter.
What did it feel like when you,
when you did have these drunk and stoned
moments when you came up with a song
like sweet emotion or riff or.
And then all of a sudden you're
listening to it on the radio.
How,
how fucking surreal is that?
What does that like?
I remember we used to go up to um,
first of all,
most of our first stuff was recorded
down in Hell's kitchen.
I'm in New York with the record plant,
you know,
John Lennon had a studio upstairs and we
were down in studio way with Jack
Douglas and um,
so we went from there for the seventies
and then end of the seventies.
I don't every drug on the planet that I
could because I thought it was cool and
if I didn't I wouldn't be cool.
And those were the kinds of people I
hung out with.
You can't do that dude.
You ain't fucking shit man.
So.
And you get early eighties.
Totally full bar.
80 four 85.
80 six.
What was eighties coke?
A lot of the hard stuff.
Yeah,
70 snorting heroin,
snorting coke.
The sixties and seventies was sixties
was we'd write,
bringing,
getting jiggy with,
you know,
with the stuff that was happening with
the English invasion.
Listened to Elvis and checking shit out,
you know?
Um,
and what about the seventies?
Seventies finally supposed 65.
Sixty four.
I started.
I was a drummer in a band at school.
You know,
the Burlington school drama,
then I bought a set of drums because I
wasn't getting looked at and get made
fun of and called,
you know,
Lipo and Lithuania and got beat up after
school and then I thought if we get a
little band together and play as lunch,
have you really cool?
We recall the maniacs,
so we played a lunch and I went,
Holy Shit.
Marcy,
Marcia resnick is talking to me now.
Holy Shit.
Whatever.
Yeah.
Isn't it funny?
There's always one girl high school,
kill Ellsworth.
Whew.
That was her.
And she looked at me and no one did
before.
It was no different than,
you know,
human.
So then 65,
66,
67,
chain reactions.
Sixty eight.
The strangers.
Sixty nine was woodstock.
I went early and left.
Three days later I still have a coca
cola cooler.
We,
the day it was over.
Okay.
We tried to start a paccar and too much
water got in the gas.
We couldn't,
couldn't get lost and everybody left and
all their tents and sleeping bags were
just left there.
Hundreds of acres of tents.
There's no pictures on it.
I walked around and I thought,
so I stole a coke cooler and I still
have that to this day.
Still haven't.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But I was a great from Coca Cola,
like they were selling your shit and
just,
you know,
where the opening on the side,
but I remember walking down this path,
it was called groovy way and I stole.
I stole this banner off the trees,
which we used for the,
for errors within the beginning I had
these girls duplicated.
So it was,
it was two guys looking at each other,
you know,
smoking a joint and at that was the
aerosmith thing in the beginning.
But when I was at Woodstock,
I'm walking down groovy way and it was,
where can keasy and the magic,
the pranksters had older buses,
so I'm tripping on acid and these
helicopters are coming by with 500
pounds of hot dogs and they're dropping
them,
dropping them in the field.
You hear this,
I'm sure you're not.
And then another giant pile of pots and
pans to cook the hot dogs.
I mean,
it was a disaster area.
Woodstock,
you know this,
right?
Yeah.
Anyway,
so I grabbed the pots and pans.
I started,
so when the guy walks over and he's
going,
okay,
another guy comes over and he starts
doing this.
By the time I was done in an hour later,
there was 50 people banging on every
pot.
That was a moment and then when I got up
from that tripping my ass off,
I walked down a path and walking towards
me was one guy and it was joey cream
with my trauma who I knew from high
school,
but then I met there later on to become.
I was a drummer for aerosmith in the
beginning.
Move forward now,
six or 70,
all the bands that broke up.
I went up to sunapee.
I was mowing the lawn at place called
Trial Rico.
My family place that I did my whole
life.
It's what I do,
or I'm a country boy.
Three hundred and 60 acres that my
Italian family bought that came over
from Calabria in 1918.
Ninety five brothers.
There were musicians,
so they worked in New York City.
They made a little money,
so for four grand they bought 300 acres,
so every year of my life when I was born
in fucking 1940.
I mean it's like what,
how,
you know,
I know I was 70 couple of months ago,
but I feel like I just,
when people would say that,
it was like what?
My daughter,
my daughter Chelsea would say,
it's a big one,
dad,
you got to stay here.
We got to celebrate it.
And I,
I know I have no concept of time.
I feel like on one hand I've lived 300
lives already and the other I feel like
it just.
How does that,
what's that number?
That's a fuck of a big number.
Does it feel like it just happened?
Oh,
it definitely,
like you look back and think of like
aerosmith's first gigs and feel like
God,
it just feels like a couple of years
ago,
a couple of years ago,
couple years ago when.
That's the thing about aerosmith.
Okay.
So we went up in Santa Fe.
He drove by in his leg and his glasses
with white tape in the middle.
I'm telling you,
man,
hair down to here.
Come on man.
Come here.
My band.
So I went and heard him.
It was a jewel Perry project.
No,
it was uh,
um,
the jam band Joe Berry Jam band.
And they were the only one.
Someone who was good.
I won't get into it because they
couldn't,
you know,
they weren't in tune and shit,
but they played rattlesnake shake,
you know,
by um,
um,
Mick fleetwood,
you know,
fluid Mac.
And when I heard that I said I sat there
and I went,
life flashed all the bands that I was
in.
I broke up.
I know why.
And I knew that if I take all the shit
that I know and put it into that and try
to carve that shit out.
If we can live together,
smoke weed together,
fuck girls together in the same
apartment,
we'll have it.
And all I want to do is get my fucking
toe in the door.
That's all I ever wanted to do.
If I could just get into the comedy
club,
another feel.
Fuck yeah.
Yeah.
So when we moved to Boston and I'm the
drummer and one day rates of ant or a
guitar player at the time walks in and
goes,
yeah,
I got a friend of yours because I didn't
really want to play the drums here
behind everybody.
You know,
you get pissed off.
Your wife wonders why you're not on the
cover of something.
Right.
So I want to be lead singer because I
want to get laid.
Well,
what do you want to do?
Tommy Lee was the drummer.
Oh,
well he had a fucking 12 inch cock that
helped.
Okay.
That helps.
That's good looking guy too.
Tommy Lee,
right.
What?
That helps.
But they have to see it first to know
and believe me,
they showed it.
We used to.
We were up in Vancouver doing our best
records and Nikki Sixx,
dear friend of mine,
he was in my way with me and I said,
you know what man,
we got to climb to the top of that hill.
You've got to stop smoking.
And we did.
We climbed to the very top of the hill
right above new beach,
little beach and big beach.
Anyway,
it's fuck,
it's like this.
He was like,
and we quit smoking and he got sober.
We went to a meeting that night and
everything.
I got up to Vancouver and there in
Studio B.
We're in studio a.
he's with a Bob Rock.
They're producing this album called and
they asked me to sing on it and Dr
[inaudible],
right.
[inaudible]
and the fucking record.
It was one of the first times musicians,
when you get your shirt put on a
protools and it gets fixed into you
anymore.
See,
I'm from the old school where if you
practice and get good,
you're good.
So what you did at the comedy store the
first time you can do in your basement
in front of your kids,
we just as good.
So don't you think so pro tools for
musicians.
It's like it can,
it can take your,
your vocal and fix it.
You can take your drums and put it in,
fixed it to a grid.
Does that do what are you going to do
better?
But it does make the music sound better,
but never listened to charlie watts.
Right?
Right.
He drags so beautifully and Keith
Richards,
but that wasn't my point is it?
Is there.
There's something missing from that.
Right?
The soul is gone because now it's
computerized and even though it's really
good,
it's still not the same as listening to
James Brown just thinking about this.
Yeah,
they got a new song,
each brand,
but yeah,
if they're all using pro tools and
fixing shit.
Yeah,
it's the same sound coming out right
now.
Maybe a different singer,
but sustained feeling.
Right and you,
by the way,
you can do it really professionally.
You can look in my eyes.
Some of my dear friends Marti
Fredrickson,
Nuno Betancourt,
these fuckers gotta get behind it and
ready for your vocal.
Yeah.
I will come up with a hey jade head.
You got your Mama's style,
but show yesterday.
Child to me,
done.
Recorded.
They move it there.
They've got the drum and saying,
go,
listen.
You think we've got a song?
And I go,
you think that that's how easy it is?
That's how he and I've done that many
times.
Do you miss the raw?
No.
Changing,
no adjusting,
no one a women saying I've done that
many times.
I've taken like,
what did I do that on pink?
I'm down in Florida.
Uh,
I'm at the island hotel.
I'm living in the room.
I'm sober as can be.
When I say that,
that means like when the sun went down
and I turned the light on and I start
reading pink is,
you're in a minute.
Loops obsession.
Pink
ain't even no question
pink
on the lips or your lover
pink,
what you will discover.
And I think it's just,
that's how it went,
right?
So I did that for until the sun came up
and I turned the light off.
So use that time period of the night for
the whole album.
That whole album was.
I wrote everything at night when I was,
I would get so tired,
I feel stoned and I would write and then
I would take the lyrics of pink and I
wrote seven verses,
which you only needed three,
but I wrote seven aerosmith's biggest
secret.
Wrote 21 songs.
Only put 14 on an album.
Hello?
Pick the best out of 21.
You're going to have a good album that's
like you go in somewhere for three
months,
right in your new fucking skit,
your new skin,
and you get,
you hit on you doing your edibles or
whatever.
It gets you off.
You hit on three fucking incredible
things.
You write them through,
you come back and if you want to,
you can do all three if you want to,
on your worst day.
The worst one is great because you,
Joe Rogan,
you already know what good is.
You know what funny is,
you know how to make that,
you know,
how to weave something together.
Alright?
So I put it,
and this would be for protools to thing
called a dats.
And so the guy we're working with says,
sing that chorus,
say saying that verse.
And so we already had the course.
I sang that first.
He just put that verse in all world
versus go.
And I listened back and I went,
fuck,
we've got such a great song here.
That's how it used pro tools.
I don't use it to manipulate.
I'll never,
I'll never fixed my vocal.
Um,
but your vocals,
there's something about your vocals that
you wouldn't enhance them if you fixed
them,
like you have a raw,
soulful quality to your voice that if
you fucked with that digitized,
you'd lose all of it.
I mean,
I'm sure they can do some things that
the real artists with pro tools and move
things around.
Those still sound amazing,
but there's no errors in your singing.
You know what I'm saying?
Any crackle or pop is just gonna be
better when you learn that.
I feel that as I thought it was an
adult,
as a person who doesn't look for
perfection,
you just look for beauty.
You know,
perfection is not beauty now.
I mean it's,
it's an unattainable thing.
Chase it.
And you can get excellence and wrong
with America
right now is everybody's trying to look
for that perfection and stuff.
Fat In their ass.
He.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But there is no perfection.
In fact,
this imperfection.
I'm a perfectionist.
So for losing to the first album,
some of my first songs,
it comes once a day on the shade a
window.
Boom.
Shit,
I'm watching Janis Joplin.
I went,
what the fuck?
And Mick Jagger and fucking little
Richard,
the when the beetles are just,
you know,
Paul's,
Paul's daughter texts me all the time,
you know,
when she's beautiful,
she's fucking line or close beyond
belief.
And um,
she goes,
dad's having drinks.
Come on over.
So this was three nights ago.
God drinks coke.
You can smoke a spliff all day here with
10 bags of coke and I'll watch you.
Actually,
I just don't do it.
I understand.
I got that strength.
Know what I'm saying?
Thank you Lord.
I thank you guys.
I appreciate it.
So I walk in and I'm doesn't mean that I
want to do it while I'm watching this
one and that one do it.
I get it and want to crawl up her ass.
My friend Doug Stanhope says he's
waiting to do heroin right before he
dies.
Oh,
it's fun.
I heard.
It's amazing.
Think about it.
When do they give you more feeling right
before you die?
No,
no,
no.
That's.
I don't know what that drug is.
We have to give you something like that.
They've done that to you.
When do they give you morphine?
When you're in pain?
Exactly what?
Human isn't in pain or all the fucking
time.
A lot of people are.
They've all time.
Those who can't get their shit together
and night they go home and jerk off and
then they drink a beer and they smoke
and you know what I mean?
It's a little hard for people.
They don't make enough money.
They vote for trump.
Whatever the fuck's going on in America
right now,
I can't figure it out,
but a lot of people like I was when I
was younger,
aren't paying.
Yeah.
Girlfriends leave you here.
Pain that white picket fence in that and
the and the wife.
Eighteen years she leaves you.
You had two kids.
I'm in fucking pain.
I'm in pain,
so what's the best thing to do?
Is that the best thing to do though?
No,
it's not,
but that's why they do it.
What is the best thing to do when you're
in pain?
Well,
we have to be a little bit elevated as
humans to know what to do.
In that case,
you listen to people like Marianne
Williamson.
I don't know who she is.
She's fucking brilliant.
Do you know she has Jamie.
He doesn't fucking virtual piano.
She's just a spiritual person.
The spiritual.
When I got sober,
I started listening to her tapes.
I get on the treadmill in the morning,
you know,
because I,
I can't eat it.
I don't even feel alive unless I'm out
of breath.
That's what I get for being a musician.
I lose a pound a night on stage.
Sweating with aerosmith.
Right.
I'm up there with standing next to
fucking Joe Perry.
Really?
The last of the real rock stars you,
you stood across from him is a bad
motherfucker.
I don't know if he was stoned out with
you,
but he's.
When I get text messages from him,
like,
Holy Shit,
I fucking texts.
And I saw him in the beginning and I
knew he was something special.
I knew he was,
that.
He's got a.
he's got a recognizable.
There's certain people that have a
sound.
You know Joe has.
He absolutely has a sound.
You know as a sound.
Gary Clark Junior,
like you hear Gary Clark Jr,
play guitar.
You Go,
oh,
that's a Gary Clark Jr riff.
You know,
there's certain people that have a
sound.
Joel most certainly has a sound.
It's like he's expressing himself
through that guitar in a very
recognizable way into together,
man,
what a fucking combination that was with
his guitar and your voice and here's,
but here's.
Yeah,
and here's the trip.
In the beginning,
in the first album,
people have said,
who say on the second album a second.
Now my kind of like that peewee Herman
fucking put that because I want to sound
black.
Oh Fuck,
I'm not stupid.
I get it.
I wanted to put some fucking soul soul
in my voice.
I knew I had it and trying to force it
out.
No,
no.
What I learned was,
you know,
like from a Nat King Cole,
he's the kind of music.
I listen to it as a kid.
When I met Natalie,
I walked up behind her and I went chemo,
Como stairs,
tear behind my rump steak,
a pumping.
Who Bang,
nip care,
parliament cameo.
I love you.
She went,
no one is song that ever.
Two weeks at my daddy said to dad passed
obviously way before,
but that's,
those are the records I listened to that
was not singing his best shit.
And um,
so I wanted to say,
well,
here's what I wanted to sound.
I want to say I'm more like Joe Perry
was playing and singing really sweet and
nice.
A dream.
Sweet and Nice.
I kinda,
I kinda went there and when we wrote a
song on a waterbed,
Joe Perry and I were sitting around
smoking a big fatty and Mark Lehman was
there.
He was our road manager and we show
goes,
burn,
burn along,
man.
Man,
man,
we in there.
I'm looking at him and that was a
sentence he spoke to me and I said,
we all live on the edge of town where we
all live in.
And so when new people start,
me and all,
we'll do just a grid and got to move our
city moving in.
Some saying she taught you spoke to me
and you.
I answered,
translated it.
Well,
I would listen to the bay,
we would sit around and we would jam.
That's what we did the best and we would
create this music and I will put the
headphones on later because I'm the
lyricist and I wrote the melody.
I see you.
When I heard Joe's band,
I thought I'm going to take my dad,
vic Tallerico who went to Julliard in
New York and I grew up in the bronx,
56,
10 Netherland Avenue,
six g the apartment and I grew up under
the piano and I listen to.
My Dad would practice everyday on a
steinway.
So who lived between the notes show,
you know what I'm saying?
I love you.
Name's Joe.
I just love Joe's fucking loved you.
I fucking love you know he's my bro.
You go her.
What the fuck man.
It's always been there.
So.
But anyway,
so I took my melody.
You know what I hear when I listened to
him playing.
Whoa Shit.
When did your second album,
and you did that little sort of
expectation,
is that how you would call it a voice?
Did you,
after you heard it and you listened to
people talking about it,
did you decide to change it for the next
album?
Wow,
sending.
I did just go away for a minute,
didn't I?
Yeah.
I love it when I do that.
The,
the melody that I learned from my dad
and then listening to the music we
listened to,
you know,
Dorsey and a Frank Sinatra and nat king
Cole and,
and then Janice Joplin and affiliate
thugs who were the first ones to put on
the back of their album,
a lunatic vagina.
That's who.
So who say sang the song is 61,
the mothers of invention.
He's fucking bands.
And I went,
what?
So I thought singing really,
like my dad taught me and the notes and
write on and you know,
c,
d,
e,
F,
G A,
b.
You don't have a fuck.
Wrong,
wrong,
wrong.
You've got to.
Not only that,
but if you don't put inflections into
it,
ain't no feeling and there ain't no
meaning.
I got you lock.
I do last time.
Whoops.
Right where you say it,
but you have to feel it can't be
something you're trying to feel.
It's got to be something you actually
feel.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
But I think,
you know,
Joe,
hats off to him,
men,
um,
the way he played his guitar and
practice at night,
he fucking nod out and he'd be sitting
in his chair and the fucking chair,
the couch caught on fire to,
through with a pot of water and he's
laying smoke.
I want y'all.
What the fuck man get?
He's playing this riff and we turned it
into a song.
This kind of stuff happens so much.
And he did it away to me.
Fucking a obviously,
you know,
Tom Hamilton,
du Du,
Du,
and a sweet motion.
That's how band comes together,
you know?
And I can't tell you any other way than
that.
Magic and every inch of the way,
the reason it doesn't feel like I'm 70
and I don't feel the time.
It feels like yesterday we just started
is because every time I'm on stage,
I'm singing those same fucking songs
again,
same way,
same feeling,
same looking,
same people,
different people,
different people.
But I'm singing the same songs.
Do you know the guy that's looking to.
Anyway,
so to answer your question,
second album sounds a little bit more
Raunchy,
more in tune with Joe's guitar and I
think we found our sound second album,
third,
fourth,
fifth,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine,
10,
11,
12.
We got it.
But it took that first album,
had songs on it like walking the dog
because we were,
we ran out of songs with.
That was the only played in clubs.
I remember we had a contract.
What are we going to do?
So we wrote moving out.
Then the guys would get stoned and drink
boone's farm and I go,
come on you guys.
We fucking wrote this song,
fuck you.
And flick the joint.
So I remember getting pissed off walking
out.
They hate me when I tell this story,
but I remember being really fucking
angry walking out to his piano and
writing one way street.
Um,
I don't play guitar and I wrote about
don't go on and do it,
make it,
don't break it first on the first album.
So some great shit because I feel like,
you know,
in anger,
I didn't know what to do but I just
bought a,
used that.
So I wrote a bunch of songs and I think
it late everybody's fuse.
I think that Joe certainly lit mine.
Tom Hamilton,
his outtakes as he called him.
Sweet emotion.
That's Tom Hamilton now through
throughout this whole time.
Were you exercising back then?
Did you do things?
How do you move around back then?
Or were you just living life because you
say you,
you're always trying to be an out of
breath.
You're always doing things physically.
No,
no.
What I'm saying now is just like,
it's like when I started getting sober I
thought,
fuck,
I got a treadmill and I got into shape.
And you didn't do that before you got
sober?
No,
because we were on tour three,
three shows a week.
I was 127 pounds.
I was just skinny,
Minnie and just trying to.
There was no MTV.
We had to play by.
Just check this out,
you to wonder what drugs I took and why
people get enamored by that.
But take it out of the picture.
We got high.
I got high because my manager was
getting stoned too.
They loved it when bands were stoned
because they can hand us a piece of
paper and we would sign it.
Uh Oh.
Fifty percent of all of our publishing.
Thanks pal.
And words like in perpetuity,
he's fucking managers back then.
I can tell you the dark secrets.
Please.
Do you do your own urine or do I just
told you the dark secret is they'd get
your high and get you to on.
We all got high together,
but they knew when you were getting
fucked up.
You know here.
Sign this.
No.
Oh,
managers loved it when their bands were
fucked up.
Think about it.
Hendricks stoned out of his fuck here.
Sign this.
Yeah.
John Lennon thought what was his name?
New Broom when he got a new lawyer and
Paul was with,
with the lender.
You know,
it's,
it's what happens back then.
You get your conference today too,
right?
I mean,
the record business has always been that
way always because artists are impulsive
and they're not business wise and people
come along and exploit that.
Yes.
Very impulsive to think of what it
takes.
If you study this for a second,
what does it take for a bunch of guys
were not in love with each other.
Um,
we love.
I love.
I really love what you just said.
What's your name again?
Young.
Jamie.
I love what you just said.
Can we talk after this?
Can I.
w,
w we tell me that again so I can write
it down.
So,
you know,
say get five guys together to love what
each other's doing.
I love it with Joey Kramer.
Place Brad Whitford.
Plays Guitar like a madman.
Joe Perry,
Tom Hamilton,
you know,
to love what these guys do and then
write songs.
Who are we?
Who are.
We were fucking in writing songs for 48
years.
Still want to turn on the radio one.
I hear sweet emotion and that fucking
song I don't want.
What is it?
I didn't want to kiss your thing.
No,
no.
I don't want to miss a thing.
I just fucking.
Here's our turn.
So turn around here.
That old shit.
What magic we had,
what magic it takes for David Grohl to
sit down and scribbling.
He's a fucking for as old as he is.
He's 12.
I loved when I walked into Paul
Mccartney's party,
you know,
uh,
what's his name was walking out,
present me help.
Dr Dre was walking out.
I walked in and there was rainbow and it
was oprah and there was,
I mean everybody that I live on Maui.
So I lived there with live in Maui.
Oh yeah.
Really you don't get because everybody
thinks mallory's.
Maui Wowie back in 70.
That's still.
Well,
I don't know,
in seven,
eight,
10.
Think that I could buy.
I could buy a case of Maui buds and have
it sent right to my house.
I did it all the time from Maui.
It was called Maui Wowie.
I've heard that name before.
Anyway,
everybody you lived there right now?
I live there right now.
Okay.
Look at.
That's got to be.
But I'm in an old fashioned band.
We all get paid the same.
You okay?
Oh,
what an old fashioned fucking man.
Who does that?
He paid Rhiana how much you think she
makes a night in this and the dancers?
I don't think.
Well,
there's a big difference between the
dancers and the dancers.
And you got married.
What were the band?
It's all.
We all get paid the same.
Right?
When I took idol,
could you started making some paper?
Get that paper?
Fuck yeah.
That's what everybody made fun of me
and.
But believe me,
did you do it just for the money?
No,
but,
but no.
You know what?
I did.
Why?
Because I thought nobody knew who I was.
Everybody knows this guy singing and
nobody knew you ever use this guy.
Oh my value as a human.
My Mom's passed away and she said,
she said they need to see that side of
you.
You as a person,
but you decided that American idol was
the best way to show that.
I thought that was the first thing was
what else was.
I had no managers back then that had the
good sense to offer me anything.
I got the offer from Marti Fredrickson.
I got,
how long ago was this?
How long have you been on this for?
Two thousand.
10.
11.
Eleven to 12.
I got to sit next to j Lo and Randy
Jackson at motherfucker.
Beautiful Guy.
Jj Long.
J.
Lo's beautiful.
You know what else may need.
I think what everyone needs some word
called incentive,
right?
Is it her ass?
It was her assets time.
I looked at it a little time,
but she'd say,
you're harassing me.
And I'd say who's asked her ass?
Yeah,
I know,
but the funniest fucking thing is we
would do all three of us and I think
that's missing now,
but all three of us,
you know,
to do American idol,
you got to go to des Moines,
Iowa in a gym and you're all set up with
a whole crew and you know,
three people with these microphones,
you know,
the 12 foot mics hanging down over your
head like this.
And 12 cameras in high def up Europe was
who?
And but,
but in 50,
40 people a day would come through all
these 15,
16 year old 17 year old little trollops
with red lipstick on and push up Ross
and going to an a kid outta here,
you know,
after the eight ft,
after the 30th 40th one.
You're sitting there doing this.
Right.
You know,
so he just got,
he got to do,
you need that incentive from each other
and sometimes they will get.
So it was just shit burned out after the
40th person,
50th person.
But that's what people liked though.
There's something about American idol.
We'd like really talented people,
but we also like people who are
delusional.
Yeah.
And we trust me,
it took me about two weeks to get into
it because I told myself I am never
going to tell some young girl can't sing
that she can't say get the fuck out of
here.
Like that other guy.
You know what I don't like?
Yeah.
Simon,
I don't like your music.
Besides which it's country and I don't
like country.
I heard him say that.
That seems not that super,
but that's also foolish.
He's a weird case,
isn't him,
because he's not a singer.
Well,
you know what,
he's.
Whatever he is.
I said,
I'm singer.
How can I say that to a girl?
It's going to be.
There may be some days breastfeeding her
baby and wants to sing.
Maybe she wants to.
Her baby's sick and she's sitting on her
bed on the bed and wants to sing,
but J-lo told her she can't.
I didn't have it in me.
I'd rather like.
You shouldn't have it in.
You mean that's his Shtick,
right?
His shtick is to be a mean guy.
And people liked that.
They liked that mean guy shit.
They would,
they would say to me,
it kind of take it up a notch.
Say that,
that the producers send them.
They don't want the fuck they're doing.
They're the ones who,
uh,
they got me a couple times ago the day
they got you to turn it up and then you
feel bad about it.
Disingenuous.
Well,
you know what I mean,
like there will be,
it will be moments where we were in,
like I said,
were some Texas.
I look over and the boom started going
like this,
right.
And we started getting it in.
They would say number one because it was
in the shot,
you know,
and then so I would whip out my,
a Limerick,
you know,
those.
I got time for a lumberjack and stop
everybody when we stop,
I say something like,
you know,
a metaphor from Dallas.
She's a dynamite stick for a Phallus.
They found her vagina in North Carolina
and her asshole and Buckingham Palace
and the fucking,
you'd see the boom going like this,
the place where it was just enough to
bring it up.
And we finished two more than we leave,
but it was fun like that.
And it was a good payday.
So when you're asking me to have a house
family.
Yeah.
And I was made fun of,
for doing that.
Well,
who made fun of you for doing that?
Joe Perry didn't think it was a smart
thing.
He said that's one step under Ninja
turtles and he's my bro.
And I read that and I thought I went,
what the Fuck Joe?
Keep in mind when I'm alone by myself,
I went,
does he?
Right.
When do I thought to myself what?
Bob Dylan do this.
Oh yeah.
I had those thoughts were.
I kind of fucked me up for a minute,
but then I went saw dylan doesn't have a
house on my way,
does it?
No,
I didn't have one.
Then what?
I wanted one.
Got a house.
He's like much,
much money.
That guy has got.
I'm sure he's probably got a house in
the middle and I know I never.
I see.
Bought a house on malware with the money
from idle.
This is where we started.
You have kids right now,
your youngest is what?
She just turned eight.
Eight.
Okay.
I have,
I have my two last kids,
Chelsea and Taj.
We lived in Marshfield,
Massachusetts and when it could,
I would take them to either Disneyland
or world or Maui.
Go to the four seasons and discoverable
right with your kids.
But every morning I'd wake up and they
would run to the right and go all the
way down to La perouse and I run back,
I think five miles down and five years
back.
How we saw this house I thought is that
we're,
I need to know who lived there.
But I thought somebody was the lead
singer of the grateful dead and Jerry
Garcia.
So I.
Rumor was he lived there.
I kept looking at it and I just use this
beautiful house.
But it was a ridiculous amount of
millions.
You,
I don't have that,
you know,
you don't have that when you're in a
band,
you share all the money plus management
publishing.
And then that contract was signed.
I mean,
come on.
So you're into mma?
Yeah,
we're going to slip.
What a segway.
Right.
Beautiful.
So I'm looking at.
I'm to fuck my notes.
Help me.
I want to talk to you about aliens.
Oh really?
Let's go with that.
And her.
Where the fuck is.
You've got a lot of notes in front of
your mat,
but the most.
I never even finished that week.
That's okay.
Okay.
We can do whatever you want,
man.
No,
we're good man.
This,
this radio is really important.
She's giving.
So when did you compile these?
This morning.
Just decided that.
Yeah,
I finished a vocal last night.
Eleven up Nuno Betancourt's house.
Got to bed.
I couldn't sleep until four.
I'm going,
what the fuck?
What the fuck?
Oh Man.
You're sweet man.
Your sweet tooth.
It's mean one format to talk truth.
Not only that,
when people watch your show,
they know whose default the shit and
who's not.
I'm for sure after awhile.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Once you.
But the ones that are telling the truth,
they know that too and I think you're
taking it up a whole shit load of
notches.
Well,
this is what you were saying about
American idol.
Like before they knew you was just the
guy behind the microphone.
You sang songs that touched people and
move people.
She,
she just put it right over there.
Oh,
she wants a different stack.
But even that,
like this,
having a conversation like this,
it's a,
this is not enough of these out there or
will.
There is now,
you know,
now there's more of them,
but,
but for the longest time,
but you would never be able to have this
kind of conversation because of the same
people that would tell you to turn it up
a notch on American idol.
That'd be producers around.
It'd be people trying to fuck with
things,
adding their recognition,
and this is my,
the studio notes.
We have notes is what we want you to do,
Steven,
and then we want you to talk about this
and stop doing that thing where you keep
singing.
People don't want to hear that anymore,
but we want you to do is this
and for you to speak your mind like you
do your truth and have someone across
from you to speak their truth in their
words,
in any language they want and not be
edited or audited is unreal.
Isn't that weird though that?
That's unusual.
Just think about it.
Forty years ago you couldn't.
Couldn't say ass on the radio.
I don't know if you can now.
I think you can now,
but I hear a shit hole.
I'm on CNN.
I watch don lemon.
Don Lemon.
Yeah,
yeah.
One of my favorite guys,
you know,
for for like three weeks,
quoting trump news and shit hole
countries was great.
I went to Divi up,
well it is a new freedom in terms of
that,
but I think it's because of the
Internet.
People are getting used to swears
they're going to use to people just
speaking on edited.
They're getting used to uncensored
video.
They're getting used to things.
Well,
it's just words.
There's this uncensored behavior,
right?
Is beyond his way past the word.
Fuck sure.
The words are just representative of
thoughts and intent.
Just noises.
It's like the best way to describe
what's going on in your head is used all
the words.
Use them all.
Use the ones that are really coming out
of your head.
Don't hold them back and give me some
watered down version of what your real
thoughts are so I have to decipher it
and sort of put it through a filter and
try to figure out what it Steven mean by
that.
I got so angry at the way things were
going about that I want to say six years
ago.
Then I quit management,
I got my lawyer,
Dina Lapolt,
equip management to management.
Well,
I got the management that was managing
the band right,
and they're also going now,
God bless,
one of them passed away.
Rest his soul.
He was a good man and the other one
didn't have a lot of good things to tell
the wrong direction all the time.
And now my band is with my management.
We're together a fucking game.
So six years ago I would talk to people
that go,
you know what?
Fuck you.
I'm going on Rogan next week and I'm
going to fucking say your name.
I mean I just built a house up in Laurel
Canyon.
He's fucking guys.
I come home and I'd have water wall and
you know,
this guy,
Lee and people would come and go and go,
don't tell fucking tire.
I want to lean back so the water wall
wouldn't rolls down,
rolls down,
and wouldn't spray on the bridge.
That goes across,
not a chance.
So after a year I get there and they go,
no.
You know what I heard?
They hired him.
Say,
fuck tyler.
No,
I'm just,
I'm just saying so that's the kind of
stuff I went.
I'm on Rogen.
You're fucking toast Powell.
That manage your story is a story that
you hear.
I just heard it from a friend of mine.
She was telling me about her manager is
given a shit advice and she just dropped
them.
Why is it so many people in management?
That gives shit advice like.
Well,
because.
Because out of 10 out of 10 of them to
to have know the answers and they may
be.
They may be right.
Yeah.
The rest of them knew how to play the
game.
If you read the book,
it's easy to management.
It just got to tell them what they want
to hear.
Yeah.
Sweet.
Talk them.
Well,
no,
no.
It's a hard thing to be a manager's.
It's to.
To manage your band.
It's even harder.
The hardest thing is to know direction,
to look at people's feelings,
right?
Know what they're about,
why they're about what w,
W,
what guy in the band should do this
interview,
what interviews to do,
which ones do which ones not to do,
which ones not to do?
Well,
don't do anyone where they're going to
stop it in four minutes.
You know those tonight?
Show one.
Sometimes you have to.
That's all they gave you.
GotTa take.
It just seemed so fucking forced and
fake.
Weird.
Your book sell books stands for me.
I wrote a book on how so fucking pissed
I wrote.
Does the noise in my head bother you?
Right to people.
I would say that I go,
what the Fuck's wrong with you?
What are you talking about?
What do you mean?
Did I write lyrics?
What did you do last night?
The guys would give me shit for not
writing lyrics or finishing a song.
They were upset that you were writing a
book.
No,
no,
no.
Back when you're writing a song and
being in band,
right?
We were in a studio.
We put the song down,
you lay the track down,
and then Stevens got to go and write the
lyrics,
right?
W If I don't,
then next day they go,
what the fuck man?
And I say,
well I'm trying to get my wife pregnant.
Okay,
I have life.
I get it.
What were you doing last night?
You know?
But those are kind of,
that's kind of shit that happens.
You get a lot of pressure on you.
And then because they did that,
I went and wrote,
walk this way,
the lyrics had them in my bag,
finished the whole record,
gotten a fucking cab,
went to 3:50,
one west,
3:21
west,
40 the record plant in New York right
out of the cab.
Went upstairs,
went,
I got it.
And I f I fucking went white.
I left the lurks in the camp,
the whole album.
And my producer goes,
we're doing walk this way tonight.
So I went upstairs,
took a pencil,
listen to the track like I did the night
before that wrote the lyrics and wrote
them on the wall.
And that's what happened.
But whoa,
but you know,
no one in the band thought I,
I left the box.
Has got those lyrics in that cast
somebody.
But the.
But he thinks you fucked off the worst
part yet.
The band went.
Yeah,
right.
He left the lyrics in the cabin.
You know what?
Maybe when you're stoned on coke and
when you're still a coke,
nothing's funny.
It's really a suck ass drug.
That's why I avoided it.
Good for you.
Thank you.
Speed could get you.
Well.
You know what,
I'm,
I think the move to speed,
but we'll.
Well this coffee right here.
What I'm saying.
It's good.
I can feel it downers for me and how I
look at you.
You're shaking your head stem cell
shots.
Put my shoulder today.
Uh,
come on.
That's what it is because they take him
out of here.
I,
there's some new process they do.
I'm in serious pain right now.
Oh Man.
That's why I'm shaking.
Like watch.
I could barely breathe.
I thought fuck his coffee.
I'm doing it stops.
Look,
if you just caught me five hours ago,
I don't believe it.
Like a perfect.
Something like something.
Suppose I'll be okay in a day.
What do I take for my feet?
Get?
Yeah.
Gabba.
Gabba panic.
It's a great drug.
It's not.
You don't get high from it,
but it kills me.
This is to alleviate some shoulder.
I have some
tears.
She's work out.
Yeah,
I can see.
so she's a great.
By the way,
let's go quickly back to your book.
Yeah,
no,
it isn't always in my head.
While you.
I wrote this and I wrote you a little a
suite that you averse.
We just remember the less hair I got.
The morehead you get,
the more,
the less hair you got the morehead you
get.
That makes sense.
Do you think love Steven Tyler Stevens.
What I say?
He said Steve,
I think I said Steven Tyler,
let's go back pay,
but I'm pretty sure I've never seen
Steve Tyler ever so I don't care,
but thank you man.
I really appreciate that.
If you put me down in the worst way,
I still love you.
I didn't do that.
I'm just saying because because of the
show and because of the trails you've
left in life.
I love you.
I love you too,
man.
I'm just telling you,
I've been a fan of yours since I was a
kid.
You're fucking monumental.
I love you man.
Love.
It's getting weird.
No,
I just fucking love your truth.
So you were telling me about this
fucking shoulder shit.
Why are you so big?
Wrestling and stuff?
No,
I switch it up a mostly right?
Yeah,
for that.
No.
Are you going to martial arts?
Jujitsu?
Mostly,
but uh,
my shoulders or they've got some issues
from some years of abuse and tears and
some minor arthritis.
And this one's been.
Apparently I had some sort of separation
on this one some time in the past and I
didn't know it was a lot of tears.
So,
uh,
I've had some great success with stem
cells.
Mesenchymal,
how do you say it was?
Cycle.
Whatever.
Anyway,
stem cells had that sucked out of my hip
bone and hip bone and they put it in my
knee.
I had a knee replacement.
Oh,
you had to replace whole thing.
You walk very well though.
Well,
what was wrong with your knee?
It had a 99 degree valgus.
It was like this.
Ooh,
from.
Because I had an acl reconstruction.
I had both of those done.
Don't try.
Don't believe that the doctors don't.
Nine years,
nine years.
I said for someone like you,
No,
no.
I've one in my left knee that's 24 years
old and still working awesome kicks with
everybody.
It's,
it's all about meniscus.
It's about the amount of cushioning and
whether or not they do a good job
replacing the ligament.
But I had very good doctors on my left
and right knee.
Shout out to Dr Getelman.
Wow.
Good for you man.
Mine.
It didn't work.
So it started going inwards or did you
get it done?
Forget what?
Ninety eight.
Mm?
Yeah,
mine was 94.
Um,
I have a buddy 93 actually.
I have a buddy of mine who had one done
though and his knee is really fucked up
to the point where he is about to get a
replacement and he actually got a hip
replacement on one of his hips because
of the damage in his
knee.
Yeah.
Because if the knees going in,
then this is pushing that way and I
didn't know any of this shit.
I just.
I knew I couldn't take vicodin or
percocet one.
That's how long ago did you get your
knee replaced?
Six years.
Yeah.
It's rough.
Last five,
six years old.
Now I got to get the right one done.
So now I'm going to Europe with my love
of loving merry band.
I got a country album.
So you need to get your right one done.
Yeah.
Because what's going on with the left
knee?
Never hurt.
Right?
But never.
Never pinching.
No nerves.
Nowhere.
No.
How right knee.
It's fine.
Except the US.
The right side.
If it pinches on the nerve,
it goes out like that.
I can't be doing that on stage.
We've seen a rolling stones going to be
gone.
He's fucking stone again.
Look at.
Do you think they would say that?
No.
I don't know.
Pictures.
Rolling Stones.
A bunch of different people though.
You can't really attribute it to them.
No,
I'm not worried about that.
I'm just worried about it doesn't.
Do you sure that that's the only way to.
Do it though,
have you talked to other doctors because
what they're doing now with
regenerative,
or can I say that?
Virginia regenerative.
Why did that one stumble with
regenerative medicine?
They're able to replace meniscus,
cartilage,
regrow shit you might want to hang on.
They're able to do some shit now where
they can.
They can fix things they've never been
able to fix before and every year it
gets better and I'm pretty close to the
cutting edge of this stuff.
Yeah.
I've had a bunch of doctors on my
podcast talk to me about it,
particularly Dr Neil Riordan,
who does a lot of work down in Panama
that they can't do in the United States,
and he did a Mel Gibson and Mel Gibson's
dad who was 92 at the time and on
death's door in a wheelchair.
Now he's a hundred and he's walking
around.
Yeah,
I know about those people down there are
people up in the go go to Panama,
but pen and Berg is one name that did my
knee and my knee is so fun.
You wouldn't believe it if you saw so
it's fine moves good.
The lefties good,
but it's so pinches,
right?
Fuck.
I mean it just goes out so I can't go on
a tour with aerosmith jumping around
like a like I do you know,
if there's other.
I'm just saying this,
I'm going to try.
I don't know how your knee is.
I don't know what's going on with it.
You got to give me names.
I will 100 percent,
but there's other options now and
there's.
It's one of those things where according
to the doctors that I've spoken to,
the longer you can hold out,
the more likely you are to never need
surgery that there,
especially when it comes to replacements
and they're able to do a lot with hip
replacements now with Regena keen and
stem snow's yeah,
the longer you can wait because what
they're able to do now is different than
what they're going to be able to do in
five years and in 10 years and the
longer you wait,
the more elite is.
They can regenerate tissue.
Yeah.
They're doing all kinds of crazy shit
now with stem cells.
Well,
now that they're in La,
they're allowing this a guy alive that
isn't your telomeres.
Telomeres.
Yeah.
That's your longevity gene.
Sure.
And he says that people that are like
found the Lord hire excellent people
that you conduct bands.
He's silly guys and shit.
Silly musicians who silly,
silly,
silly me Comedians,
right?
People that are able to let,
let a childish side of them out,
those little Tali tells stay longer old
people.
They grow shorter,
at least close to finding that out.
So I love,
I love today.
I love what's going on.
I'm going to look into this.
Do,
we'll talk afterwards.
I'll give you names,
numbers and shit to,
to look up.
But.
So,
so I'm,
I'm,
I'm a,
I'm looking at it and one of the girls
that works for me,
um,
said,
well that's the same thing as what
you're into right now.
MMA for me,
I'm a diamond may only use.
It's something.
None of it's something I got into in the
last year with my lawyer Dina lapolt and
it's called.
I'm sick and fucking tired of getting
beat and ripped off for the songs I
wrote in the seventies and where's the
money?
Where's the money?
It's not even a joke,
right?
It's not even a joke and now that
there's a format that's digital,
it's even less of a joke.
You want to fucking go break into these
buildings and take a gun and shoot
people because they're not paying you.
You mean things like spotify and they're
not paying you.
They're taking the money for plays of
your song.
They're giving you what?
First of all,
publishers,
you know what?
It's all about.
100 years ago,
50 years ago,
20 years ago,
publishers take the money we make on
toys in the attic.
Millions,
right?
They keep that money for a year.
They put it in the bank.
They keep the interest right.
Then they pay you after they keep the
interest.
Of course,
that's one of those members before is
here.
This so many things.
I can tell you.
How about us,
how it finding out managers by the first
three rows of your shows and get the
money from the fucking promoter in their
pocket,
brought to them in a paper bag.
You want to fucking go there.
That what does.
Is that what happened with that kind of
shit that.
No,
it's kind of shit that happens in a
business.
So they buy the first three rows.
Then so how simple.
That is.
Simple.
They go up to the guy that's the eyes.
Assuming that the show,
right?
If you have a 90 slash 10 deal,
fucking great.
The manager goes and goes to first three
rows,
see you later or you don't get
aerosmith.
Wow.
Well you don't get Bob Dylan.
Well you don't get Jimmy Buffett and
they're just depending upon those people
to not tell you.
Yeah,
I mean,
who's going to tell you?
Because here's what happens.
You only find that shit out afterwards
if you're going out with a girl that
says,
I'm the one that brought the money back
to him.
Oh Shit.
Is that how you found that?
I still have.
I found out somebody found out that way.
The story I heard,
oh,
let's keep it like that.
This a story of this woman is willing to
talk about it.
Oh,
but,
but the deal,
here's the deal,
you know,
I'd love to get angry and shit about
stuff.
I love that.
I'm gonna tell you and you kidding.
You know what's so funny?
I got sober,
right?
And then when you have an anger
management problems giving,
once you get sober,
I fuck you what you want.
You know what I mean?
Here's the,
you know,
you,
you think when you get sober,
you're off the drugs,
your isms or wasn't bullshit all.
You're all the reason you drank for all
the reasons that you drank.
They come out even more,
right?
And then you have to manage all that and
you gotta learn.
You gotta.
Learn how that's a good thing.
We'll exercise.
Right?
Well,
you know,
you just got to read certain books,
PML and you don't feel your
codependency.
No more shit.
Shit.
You know,
shit stuff.
Spiritual stuff.
How to rise above your,
your,
your abnormalities.
It's not so good to smack your wife when
you get angry.
Definitely not.
No,
he is it you to learn how to,
what to how to manage that anger for
sure.
While it wasn't too about.
I got sober and 88.
So you do the math.
Um,
because it had enough for those years,
right?
I was out of my fucking mind.
Eighty one,
82 83.
So he got sober in [inaudible] 88,
[inaudible] 88,
14,
15 years.
Then I had,
you know,
don't want to kiss you.
Don't miss a thing.
Came out right.
And I'm up and I'm up in A.
I know we're jumping around but disagree
show.
He's good to use these as bites,
you know?
Right.
Let's just talk.
I think so man,
we went up to a place where he'd never
played.
So what I was getting to before point,
I really want to make strongly no cell
phones,
no Mtd,
nothing.
I used to buy these plastic stickers and
I got to go around to each guy's room
with 13,
25 comment and ask them for 20 bucks and
we'd get 60 bucks.
I get these stickers with aerosmith on
it and I would put them on people's
windshields,
piss them the fuck off because it was
really sticky and I put them where you
throw the money when you go through a
toll booth.
Right?
I put them to good mood so everyone will
say,
what's that?
What's that mean?
Aerosmith?
What does this Arrow you come up with a
name.
We just sat around.
Hookers,
shit stains,
jets,
you know,
just he just,
he throws shit around.
Someone said Aerosmith,
Joey Kramer goes,
how about aerosmith?
And I went,
the fuck does that mean he goes,
well you.
I used to be in a band and we were.
We were called Arrowsmith for awhile and
so there was another aerosmith before.
Well,
it wasn't that I heard from the drummer
who was always bad.
It was just a really short lived club
thing as an idea.
So maybe there was a band that performed
a couple of times called arrows.
Maybe.
Maybe,
maybe who know me.
Are they alive still?
Well,
all I know is this.
For all the names I heard and thought,
that's a good one.
I didn't see anything into it.
Like I,
I have this knack of looking at someone
and not necessarily remembering their
face,
but,
but I feel you.
I'm like stupid.
I had explain this.
It's a vibe.
It's like,
oh,
you don't have one of these.
No,
I don't.
Yes,
you do.
I definitely do.
You do.
Now.
I definitely don't.
You don't have this,
you know,
I guess I'll leave that.
I'm going to show up.
It's your thing.
But where the fuck were we?
So,
so when you kind of.
I kind of feel things I feel.
I don't remember.
It's like Brad Pitt's got this disease.
I don't know what Brad Pitt as a
disease.
He's got this thing where I can't
remember people.
Propofol Fabia.
He can't remember faces.
Is that what it is?
I'm still looking.
That's a good way to tell people.
If you're Brad Pitt,
like,
I'm sorry man,
I have a disease.
I can't remember you because you
probably meet so many people that are
like,
Brad a fucking met you 15 years ago.
Starbucks.
You don't remember,
dude,
I swear people come up to me and say,
yeah,
I'm sure you remember.
Yeah.
You said I have proper.
That's fucking written down everywhere.
Everywhere,
but right here.
Let's start telling people I got that
shit pro portfolio via.
You can look it up.
Look it up.
It's ridiculous.
Developmental Pros.
So pag,
nosy face blindness.
Yeah Bro.
That's what I got.
Yeah,
but,
but you know,
not on a large scale,
but I'm backstage and they,
you know,
it took me like 25 years to be able to
go,
you know,
I just don't remember.
Fill me in on it.
You know what I mean?
It took me three years to.
Do you know what dunbars numbers?
No.
What does a number that you can keep of
intimate relationships,
like friendships and close ties with
people that you know in your head and
then somewhere around 150,
which they think is roughly about the
size of tribes that people lived in back
when we were developing the human.
Your genes really take a long time to
change and they think that we
essentially have very similar genes to
people that live roughly 10,000
years ago,
10,000
years ago.
That's essentially how people live.
They live in these small groups of
people.
One hundred and 5,200
people max.
And that stuck in your head.
That's it.
Then there was another million people
here a million years ago.
There was another million people.
If you don't think so,
what do you mean you don't think there
were people here before the last ice
age?
They went underground?
Yeah.
That's not what you want underground,
don't you think?
I don't know.
The Grand Canyon goes cage shit.
Places they went underground.
I don't know.
I think so.
Well,
from just talking to and watch people,
just people,
people that live 10,000
years ago,
we can go back to that.
It's just the number.
There's a reason why you can't remember.
So many people.
You believe that.
What do you believe?
Uh,
I,
I feel feel as though
there were people here a long,
long time,
long,
long time ago.
I read Graham Hancock and that stuff,
he makes a lot of sense that there's
been periods of massive loss of life and
cataclysms and comments passing by.
Yeah.
Um,
I believe that we're having not watched
unacknowledged.
What is unacknowledged?
You gotTa Watch unacknowledged.
What does that one?
Okay.
You got to watch you and ignore what is
it?
You got to watch her and acknowledged.
Is that that Steven greer movie?
No,
it is.
Yes.
Yeah.
Listen to me,
man.
No,
no,
no.
This is this.
An industry and the industry is in
people wanting to get mystery solved.
The great mystery of is there life out
there and nobody has any answers.
I did this show for Saifai called Joe
Rogan questions,
everything.
And before that show,
I was a hardcore believer in a lot of
wonky conspiracies,
like big foot and aliens.
I just loved them because they see foot.
You don't live in big fund.
I don't believe it's the most plausible.
He thinks so,
yes.
Why?
Because there was an animal called a
gigantic pithy kiss that lived alongside
human beings as recently as 100,000
years ago.
It was a real.
Absolutely real animals and there's
found fossilized bones,
these things,
and they found teeth from an apothecary
shop and China there was a real animal,
was a gigantic bipedal hominid.
There was somewhere around eight to 10
feet tall.
So this thing lived at the same time
people did.
So this is probably the reason why
there's this myth of big foot that at
one point in time this was a real thing.
And what about the.
What about the.
They're walking around now?
Probably not.
I sort of.
Most likely not.
That was what I was saying.
Yeah,
sure it was.
Jerry put this,
you know about aliens.
Tell me about the most is a business.
Most of it is.
What about,
what about the air force general consent
to Kate,
did that tape,
gave it to his wife and said,
don't put this out until I'm dead.
Did you not feel as though when he was
speaking?
Any of that was real.
I think you've seen that way.
I think too many of you seen that.
I've seen a lot of those.
I've seen a lot of those people is a lot
of.
There's a lot of former military people
that say they've seen crazy things that
it's entirely possible that they really
did.
It's entirely possible,
but it's also possible that they're
crazy.
It's possible that they love attention.
It's possible that they're bored.
It's possible their schizophrenia.
It's possible that they have memories
that they've concocted over the years
and enhancements,
gotten them attention and it's putting
them in documentaries and it gets them
interviews on television programs,
but that there's no evidence,
you know,
and the problem with all these peoples,
they're all have this same feeling about
them and then not.
There's very few of them to come across
as rational and objective.
Most of them come across as there's
something wrong.
There's A.
There's wires that aren't connecting.
If you talk to them about other things
in life,
like if you had a chance to talk to them
for a long period of time,
sit down with them for three hours,
ask them about ghosts,
psychics and all kinds of other shit.
They almost all believe in that stuff.
This is,
they're believers.
They want to believe in nonsense.
I hear you as soon as that crops up,
I'm out of the room,
but it's possible.
I mean,
not just possible.
It's 100 percent likely that this alien
life out there like 100 percent more
scared me for a second.
No,
I think it's likely that the movie,
because it kind of had a nice thread
that movie's horseshit.
There's a lot of those movies that are
horse shit and that guy,
he knows some of that's horse shit.
Like there's a little baby that they had
found as an aborted fetus.
They were trying to pass that off as an
alien baby for a long time,
but they have generally,
if there were,
uh,
there were hybrids.
No hybrid.
Can you tell me about the link between
monkeys and us?
Seriously?
Well,
between the frontal lobes and the full
one monkey.
Well we are hominids mean we are
primates and we're just the most
advanced primary.
The real question is how did we get to
be so much more than that?
I'm just,
that's why I asked you.
Well,
it's more likely when we found fire and
our diet change and hunting,
and then the stoned ape theory,
which is a very fascinating theory.
The stoned ape theory is Terence
Mckenna's theory.
They're human beings found cell site
siliciden mushrooms and that through the
use of psilocybin mushrooms,
which in low doses increases visual
acuity,
produces these ecstatic states that it
might've helped us develop language and
communication and creativity and that
this term was the reason why the human
brain doubled in size over a period of 2
million years,
which is the greatest mystery in the
history of the fossil record.
They don't know why they did it,
but there's a very clear path here to a
million years ago.
Humans,
well,
some form is some form of of primate was
certainly here tons of years ago as was
dear dear.
We're here millions of years ago.
There's a lot of animals.
You mean through our peer plate?
Oh,
it's okay.
I don't know if I feel that.
I feel like,
you know,
just because there was an ice age that
took part that took.
It was a company,
hundreds,
100,000
years was the ice age,
well,
there's been a bunch of ice ages,
but the most recent one ended somewhere
in the neighborhood of 12,000
years ago.
That was nothing.
Nothing from beginning to end and we
don't know what caused it.
Well,
when the ice age exists,
we have to remember that some parts of
the world aren't experiencing the ice
age and then humans thrived in Africa
during parts of the ice age.
I mean there's,
there's a lot of human beings that live
all over the world.
The real question is where they start
most likely from Africa,
but they could have possibly started
from some other places too and we're
starting to learn that the people,
the people that are learning.
No,
not really.
I mean there's that too,
but I mean mostly just people traveling,
but what you really learned from his
archeologists,
those,
the people you learn from and
biologists,
people that really understand the human
genome,
they really understand the differences
between people that emerge from China
versus people that emerged from western
Europe versus people that emerged from
or native Americans.
I mean,
there's so many different types of human
beings that came from different climates
and that our bodies evolved from these
places and there's real science to that.
You're not going to get that from these
goofy fucking documentaries.
These goofy fucking documentaries are
basically a business and the businesses
to.
There's a bunch of people out there that
want to want to know the answers,
what is the truth?
And so you get a board to secret UFO.
I saw the magnetic controller that makes
us travel through the cosmos and bend
time and space.
It's like a wormhole and they'll say a
bunch of sciencey sound and shit,
but there's no evidence.
Does nothing.
When they talk about there's nothing.
Will you let David know that guy says
that he is the reincarnation of Edgar
Casey?
Do you know that?
Um,
did you know that?
I've heard,
you know Edgar Casey?
Oh yeah.
Of course.
Famous psychic who never really figured
out anything and thought to be a fraud
most widely by scientists and kept
drinking too much loud,
loud them.
Don't you think?
I don't know.
I don't know what everything was written
in.
Everybody was stone Psychedelic,
second Siliciden,
mushrooms,
opiates.
Now last hundred years you get loud,
loud,
loud.
Glum allowed them.
Everyone was drinking that shit,
but.
But look,
there's,
you know,
there's.
Yeah.
That shit was in that.
A Japanese there.
They never left the island to.
A lot of Japanese have the same ice
shapes.
Yes,
they do.
Is there a reason?
Well,
there's a reason why I didn't leave the
island and come back after meeting with
anybody else.
So stayed on the land.
Do you think they're from alien?
No,
absolutely not.
It's just that they stayed on that,
that,
that plot of land.
Sure.
But when you agree to American Indians
from Asian look fairly similar.
Yeah,
I do.
There's variations in the similarities.
It was similar,
but I think it took millions of years.
That's my take look at.
I can't prove anything.
They do believe it took millions of
years.
We always finished up by saying I didn't
see it right when I go out at night
knowing walks,
walk around,
I'm dying to see with Ufo.
Me Too.
So were you every second.
I see one.
The second right.
That will make clear shit like you know
the song I wrote called back when Kane
was able way before anyways about a
mothership and chip way before I knew
anything about Ufo.
Did you ever see anything when you did
psychedelics,
when you did drugs with,
whether you did mushrooms,
saw anything that wasn't there for sure.
Not the kind of people I'm not for kind
of people.
People have though and the idea is that
there are things that are out there and
neighboring dimensions that you really
not capable of accessing them.
That that's where the real alien slip.
Yeah.
I don't know man,
but I just know that all these people
that are pushing it,
they're all.
They all have this fuckery involved and
all these people.
No,
that's a real problem.
I hear you.
I hear because
it's fun.
It's fun.
You want to believe,
right?
You want to believe that there's a
general out there that seen a spaceship.
It's under the mountain.
Tell me about it,
Mr.
General and he goes on a lecture tour
and that you've got to pay money to see
him and he's in a documentary and
there's a lot of those people out there,
man,
and I live with it.
I was backstage with Joe Perry.
What'd you do know my home life.
Yeah,
so I get what you're saying.
The wow of the thrill of the story,
but you know,
people love to tell stories.
Something inside me that says,
you know what?
They still haven't found that,
that missing link,
that betweens if you talk to biologists,
but they do.
They have all through Australia,
pithy fossils.
They have the things that were like us
that are different from a long fucking
time ago.
They have those in the size of the
brain.
Yeah.
To frontal lobe brain changed.
It doubled over a period of 2 million
years mean that that did happen,
but the.
They know what we used to be.
There are simple hominids that were,
or rather ancient hominids that are very
similar to human beings and they slowly
became human beings and there's also.
They keep finding all these different
versions of human beings.
Like,
there wasn't just human,
there wasn't just homosapiens and of
course there was neanderthals and.
But there was that,
the one from Russia.
What was that called?
That was in that mood,
that book?
Um,
Hominid what,
what is that a deal?
Dee Dee.
And I can't remember that it starts with
a d,
but it's one that they've found very
recently,
very recently.
You find a jamie?
Yeah.
Here it is.
Dennis Sovan Dennis.
So Dennis Sullivan did a Sovan hominin
extinct species of sub or subspecies of
archaic humans.
They found in the 19 seventies by the
Russian paleontologists,
Nikolai old golf.
So there's been a bunch of different
forms of humans were just the most
successful form of human.
The idea that it's just alien,
DNA connected with people.
It's sexy.
It sounds fun,
but there's no evidence here.
You isn't what we are as humans.
Well,
we are mutations.
We are an ancient thing that slowly
figured its way out and we became better
at seeing things.
We've gained better at hunting.
We became better at harnessing fire.
Freewill came from a lot of people that
don't even believe it's real.
They believe they believe in
determinism,
they don't.
Don't even believe that free will is an
actual thing.
I mean,
I've heard Sam Harris arguing pretty
successfully,
that there is no such thing as free
will,
that you are an accumulation of your
genetics,
your life experiences,
all the things that have happened to the
people that you've come in contact with.
That's true behavioral and that that
four year old psychology behavior.
Think about your behavior and how much
of your behavior is shaped by millions
of adoring fans and people screaming and
cheering you on and singing.
Songs that move people and literary
changed generations give people
goosebumps when they hear.
I mean all that stuff has shaped who you
are.
I mean all that stuff changes who a
person is and who you are now and the
way you behave now is in many ways
shaped by your life experiences as much
as as it is by your genetics and you
wouldn't be this person if you hadn't
lived that life and the decisions that
you make from this moment on right now.
Leave the studio and have a conversation
with someone who will be shaped,
at least in part by this conversation,
and mine will be my conversation with
you.
This is the idea behind determinism.
I would ask what was.
Who said this?
Who was into this many,
many people that come up with this
concept,
but I've heard it that it was really
argued to me by Sam Harris,
the most successful.
Wow.
Interesting.
I just wonder why then,
you know,
certain monkeys,
certain breeds of monkeys,
smart ones,
Benobos.
I love them because I'm a Panola.
Have stickers.
They'll put a stick in something and
pull out [inaudible],
but you know,
well that's also haven't taken going.
Well wait a minute now.
Then they haven't got any favorite.
We've gone past that.
So do you know primatologists actually
believed that chimpanzees have entered
the stone age.
This is one thing that's being
considered now that they've started to
use of tools on a regular basis.
They think that they're learning from
each other and they think that they're.
If they are evolving,
right,
and if human beings evolved over a
period of millions of years,
we are actually watching chimpanzees
evolve in real time.
This a long,
long process that'll take millions of
years,
but they have entered the stone age,
so they think that who knows,
with a series of mutations,
if natural selection with a bunch of
different things happening,
what a chimpanzee is today,
most likely it will be a different thing
and 2 million years.
Of course it will.
Yeah,
and that totally agreeing that these
intelligent animals,
they're going to experiment with things.
Here it is.
Macaques often use stolen tools have
been living in the stone age for 50
years,
so for 50 years these animals,
just 50.
Okay.
That actually about that.
That's when somebody first saw them
using the stone.
It true.
Well,
in terms of primatologists behavior,
so these archeologists have uncovered
stone tools they believe these animals
have used or other humans?
Yeah,
or other humans.
Either your stone out right now.
When you look,
what do you think about when you look up
and look at?
I don't know the answers.
That's where I got my girls.
Well,
I definitely don't know the answers
either.
Again,
remember I just said I just repeat shit.
Smart people figure it out.
That's all I'm doing.
What about the stones that are cut cut
up and not much.
You tube it up and I know what you're
talking about.
Yeah,
those laser cuts.
Well,
not laser,
but yeah.
Very precise cuts.
Yeah.
Whoever was likely advanced
civilizations that have been wiped out
by cataclysm and that's what I'm saying,
so my mind goes to fuck.
Yet we were here.
Simply wasn't run.
There's places I saw movies of it.
Where are you going to the mountain?
You go back three miles in the mountains
seeing this.
Yeah.
There's this incredible cases,
natural caves,
rooms like this and is a natural cave
systems in Texas.
They go back miles.
So mountains.
So I'm just saying,
so I should say that's where my head
goes with this.
You know,
ghosts.
Come on.
That's your own fear.
I don't know,
but you know what you're talking about.
Muscle shoals,
those,
the feeling in that room.
There might be a similar feeling when a
violent encounter happens in a house.
That might be what a ghost is,
what a ghost is,
might be this thing that you can't
capture.
You can't put it in a box,
can't wait on a scale,
but you get a feeling when you're in a
place where something horrible happened
and you could feel it.
It's not.
It's not impossible to imagine this is
the case and Rupert sheldrake was the
guy that I told you believed that and
he's a scientist and some people would
argue against it,
but that he believes that things have
memory and then it's impossible.
It's possible that even this table has
memory.
All the people that are sat where you
sat.
I think it's got a vibe.
I'm not sure if this memory,
you know,
it's got memory water.
Nobody knows about that border because
it never goes anywhere.
You can never get rid of water.
It's true.
You can boil it steam and it goes up,
comes back down.
So I think when they find out the memory
one or I also got to tell you,
for the billions of babies that was,
this is terrible or new,
strangled people with their heads bashed
in murdered wars,
billions were there,
ghost.
Where's that?
Where's that energy?
Where is that energy?
Because in New York City alone,
there were hundreds of thousands of
people murdered that Neil's apartment
building should be going like this
because maybe it's accumulation of all
experiences,
positive and negative,
and the negative experiences are
outweighed by the positive experiences.
For the most part,
most of the time,
life is pretty good.
Most of the time life is not filled with
war.
Life is not filled with cannibalism and
murder and animals eating you most of
the time.
So most of the memories accumulated in
these individual areas were probably
positive,
but sometimes the idea behind like
haunted houses and shit like that is
that something so extreme happened that
the remanence of that experience are
trapped in the very fiber of the room.
I don't know if I believe it or not,
outside the realm of possibility.
I don't either because I'll tell you who
thinks about it.
Some human.
Yeah.
They knew that.
Right.
Here's what I would test.
I would find out somewhere.
There's some unbelievable murder was
taken place.
Don't tell anybody and let 10 families
sleep in there.
See what I had taught at.
Duh.
I'm sure they have be cool.
Go shows.
You got more notes.
Have you are supported.
I just wanted to finish that thing about
mma.
I want to ask you about little tay.
It.
Yeah,
I did that for Jamie.
Little is a nine year old shit talker
who flashes money and talks about her.
Uh,
bentleys and Rolls Royces is old,
nine years old.
It's fake.
You know,
she's,
her parents talk.
So,
so,
but anyway,
mma for me is a music monitors
modernization act.
So about five,
about five,
six years ago,
Dean will uphold and I just started
looking at that and she's beautiful
blonde lawyer woman,
great woman.
Very smart,
very intelligent.
Speaks over here at Brandeis or
somewhere.
She's my lawyer,
was my manager for the longest time,
but she and decided to go to
Washington has started flashing this
shit around and saying,
you know what's fair and what's not.
Wire musician is not getting paid.
So I just thought MMA.
It's the same thing.
Music modernization,
so I won't forget this.
I sometimes forget it because my mom
can't forget.
So to attain fair market value,
royalty rates and treatment for music
creators in the digital era.
The digital,
the digital era right now is where they
can play my music was this digital over
air,
you know,
spotify and I don't get paid that.
The artists.
Fuck me,
I got enough money.
I'm the happiest guy came along.
I got move kids.
I go to sleep right fucking with a smile
on my face.
I get to do Joe Rogan.
Well,
I'm happy you just recognize the name.
Full name aerosmith with Joe Perry.
I'm happy as can be,
but I look at these poor folks like doe.
You gotta hear this well today too.
They get,
they have to give up merchandise.
They have to give up a piece of their
concerts.
Sales,
they have to give up everything.
Well,
yeah,
that's,
that's what's going on because there's
no more money in actual record sale.
It's called 24 slash seven or some kind
of bullshit like some crazy thing where
they have a piece of everything because
manager see it and they want your money.
Right?
Well they also realize that their avenue
of revenue is gone.
So then they locked onto merchandise.
They locked onto ticket sales,
which used to be all yours,
right?
Yep.
Like when you used to do concerts back
in the day,
used to get paid for your record.
Even if you got fucked over,
you got some money from the record,
but then you would get all the money for
the concerts.
Right?
But,
but well not unless we were own
managers.
Ninety 10 means we take 90 percent out,
10 percent of the Mucosa there.
So you make $800,000.
Company gets it.
Oh God,
that's different,
right?
Isn't that a different thing?
Well the record company gets,
gets publishing,
you know,
with all these digital outlets of
course.
And then the,
then the record company company decides
to give whatever is left to the artist,
which is usually little to nothing.
Smokey Robinson,
my dear friend,
I go up to this guy and I go,
ah,
don't.
But I love you seeing if that all these
songs phenomenal.
This fucking guy went to the digitals,
said you only $250,000
with proof they offered.
They offered for,
for the,
for his music being played while the
last five years.
Why do they owe him that?
Because he was getting nothing back.
Nothing was coming to him.
Okay.
He's gone.
Shit.
The coffers are empty,
you know,
it says what the fuck?
I'm smokey Robinson,
right?
I hear my music and his music is covered
by thousands of people.
The guy knew legally $250,000
was owed to him.
Okay,
okay.
He was offered 12,000
and he said,
if you don't like it,
suicide now smokey,
you don't have that kind of money.
So what we've done is the smokey
Robinson doesn't have that kind of
money.
So smokey Robinson should be just
wealthy.
Look at King.
And this is not to say he's not.
If he had no money at all,
he's one of the happiest guy in his wife
is the sweetest and maybe he's a town
attained something that you and I don't
recognize yet or,
or the mass media,
but he's got something.
He's rich.
But when it comes to him getting paid
actually for songs that's really fucked
up.
So what did he do?
So he decided to do a,
I don't know,
I don't know where it's going.
I got to talk to him.
But David Israelite,
the president and CEO of the National
Music Publishers Association and Dina,
we went to,
went to Washington magic,
this beautiful blonde in this fucking
guy.
Now we're in Washington and in me,
you know saying what's up with this?
This money is going right out the window
and knocked to the artist.
These new artists getting nothing.
So we decided to do something for the
first time songwriters will have
representatives overseeing
administration of mechanical licenses
and administration.
So someone's now,
at least not only can he complained,
but there's someone watching that goes,
no,
no.
You do in fact legally owe him $250.
Smoke.
You come here,
sit down and for the first time.
So this is something we're trying to get
passed in the next.
Don't you think it should be that?
No,
I do think you know,
that's the reason why we're not on that.
We're not on spotify and the reason why
we're not on it,
it's because it didn't make any sense.
They were like,
we want to put you on what it's going to
be great for you.
I'm like,
how's it?
Great.
Yeah,
you guys are going to make money like
you guys are making money.
You don't give us any.
It's that whole streaming thing is this
weird smoke and mirrors song and dance
they put on.
You're going to be a part of something
big.
You're like,
yeah,
but what are you selling?
All you sell is artists work.
You don't have anything to sell yet.
And I say to them,
artists get paid so little,
so little.
So where's the money going?
Because there's all these ain't fucking
pockets.
Public companies and they're traded and
they're worth millions and billions.
Like,
where's all that money?
Where's it going?
What's generating it for you?
You need to say to them,
what if I'm bigger than you are a mother
fucker,
mother fucker.
Well,
1,919.
The laws were written.
Check these out in 19.
Oh,
nine on track.
Not paid attention to until fucking
yesterday.
Yesterday.
I mean,
you know,
five,
five reasonable.
So we're trying to get the shit of
organization act gains momentum and the
Senate,
old smokey Robinson.
Powerful yesterday.
Yesterday.
Jesus Christ.
Jamie,
you're on the ball.
Wow.
So this is it right here.
I mean,
you know.
Well yeah,
there's been some fuckery.
There's been some illegal fuckery and
he,
you know,
he continues.
He created magic sky.
I said,
I said to him,
what do you mean?
I like you,
but I love you.
Seems that I'm always thinking of you.
I said,
what the fuck did you come up with a
line like I've said to Paul,
you know,
what was,
what was this?
You know,
he says,
well,
I was sent to New York to do some kind
of publishing thing with and I was
sitting in a hotel in New York right
before I went in and I thought I wrote
those lyrics.
Somehow him being young black men with
songs 50 years ago in New York with
lawyers,
probably white,
not just saying he was put in a
situation where he had the magic.
He had the magic.
He wrote a paper,
I don't like you.
I love you.
Seems maybe the hate that he had for
what was about to happen.
Created the opposite.
I don't know,
but that's what he told me.
He said I was down there and waiting to
meet my lawyers and I'm.
I said that.
Let me ask you this.
You never know when,
when napster came along,
fucking hated that prick.
Yeah,
he still might.
You say they started stealing our songs?
Yeah.
Great.
Take all the albums we've ever done.
Take all the albums.
Nuno,
Betancourt,
nick,
all the albums that fucking,
you know,
the rolling stones ever did put them in
a box over there.
Now all my friends going to have access
to that box.
Anybody can do it.
It's peer to peer.
Everyone's sharing songs and I'm sure
people are listening to me and say,
what a prick.
He's fucking rich old fuck.
But what's happened is,
is it's become the norm.
What's the norm is that people recognize
that you can't do that with movies.
Right.
They recognize that if you're stealing
movies,
it's illegal.
Like if you get caught with a bit torn
account,
you got a bunch of movies on there and
you're letting people download them.
You can get prosecuted.
Yeah.
Let me ask you why so much for that and
not for somebody songs.
Well,
there is a thing with songs too,
but it's just not as common.
Right.
Jamie is the case.
People have been sued for having tons of
songs.
Right?
I for sure the movie industry has gone
after that way.
If you're doubling their movie.
Yeah.
It's just songs,
for whatever reason,
after napster became something that
people think that you should just be
able to get for free and then we'll pass
them in the USAC and spotify and what's
the other one?
Spotify.
What's the other?
There's another one say titles.
Getting in Trello right now is title.
The company that Jay z owned with a few
other.
They're getting charged for streaming to
faking streams and not paying people and
all new bakery.
My daughter Chelsea,
she's in a band with John Foster,
her husband.
They put something out and it's fucking
ridiculous.
The Great.
Where's the money go?
Well,
this is what I'm saying to you.
When napster came along and then things
change.
Do you think that's when the music
business really got crazy?
That's when they really say,
look,
we got to start.
We're not getting money from record
sales anymore.
When the record business,
they can do the shit digitally.
We gotta get a piece of that concert
sales.
We've got to get to pick a piece of
those tickets.
We've got to get the merchant.
We've got to get everything we've got to
solidify and we've got to make still
make it a big deal and the perks and the
money grabbers from artists just
rethink.
Yeah,
streaming through streaming and
streaming seems like a more hostile
version of it,
but let me ask you some money.
The end of the day,
somebody,
executives your it goes somewhere.
You know when I watched this movie
called Vinyl,
you see that I haven't seen a
documentary on whatever when it was out
for a bit.
Mick Jagger and a Martin Scorsese,
they did a pretty good job.
They just got too into the characters
bring going fucking crazy and not enough
of what was really going on.
It was a New York dolls.
Mick Jagger song was called the squeaky
parts.
There's the nasty parts and it showed
the manager's snort and below and
thinking how they can fucking take this
and that.
It was so easy.
All the money was coming in to them.
They were making deals with the nasty
parts.
Weren't even signed to the label,
but you hear that are assigned to the
manager and the manager at a secret deal
rather than Sony.
But you hear that about boxers have
shitty.
Can everybody,
creepy managers.
You hear it about musicians,
comedians and everything.
It's,
I hope there's kids out there right now
listening to this.
They're want to become lawyers and say,
did it.
It should be the wild wild west with
these nasty,
completely new,
a new type of lawyer.
My,
my uncle used to say,
oh really?
You have a,
you know,
another way.
When I would say things to him like,
you know,
what about these lawyers?
They took on a case,
they find out after a year and a half,
the case is still going on.
Grand jury,
but they find out that the guy that
they're tech,
they're handling really murdered the
girl.
He's not allowed to speak.
They're not allowed to speak because
that's the way we are.
Shit's got to change.
They,
they can,
they can bow out,
but usually they don't.
You know,
you know when,
uh,
when Oj Simpson was,
was,
was in a,
was caught,
right and they chased him around and our
dear friend of aerosmith's when we got
sober,
we get sober and 88,
the whole band aid.
We have a guy to come out with us every
month and we'd have meetings and make
sure everything was right and beautiful
and cool.
Or in Germany has everybody feeling girl
in the room?
You cool?
Yeah.
Everybody good?
Feeling like using fuck.
Yeah.
Are you going to know,
you know,
Shit like that.
It's really cool guy.
He was asked to go in and see Oj toxic
psychosis out of his fucking mind.
Snorted so much cocaine speed.
Oops.
Didn't mean to do that.
Hold on.
Who had toxic psychosis?
Oj Simpson.
He did.
My Guy,
he's passed away since.
Came out of there and coke and speed.
Oj Simpson.
You don't think he was on coke that I
know.
You tell me.
You tell me about.
You're the one who brought it up.
It's not out there.
I didn't hear that.
Did you hear him?
Was So.
I never got that far in the document
that.
Well,
I can only tell you that your hearsay.
Did I see in myself?
No,
no.
Um,
my sense,
my,
he was,
my guy was brought in there and I'll
tell you why because he was one of
those,
uh,
Aaa Gurus that the court system saw as
somebody that if he says Joe Rogan,
he was on drugs that night.
He didn't know what he was doing and now
the judge goes,
okay,
let's get him into Rehab and he's not
new,
but you can't do that with murder.
Nobody's going to buy that toxic
psychosis.
You cut your wife's head off day.
He was on drugs.
There's some kind of law.
Anyway,
the lawyers were looking to find someone
to say that if he was caught,
they never did a blood test on him.
But my dad was arrested.
My guy came out,
he was in jail.
He was fucking toxic.
Psychosis is when you do too much
cocaine or too much speed or too much
anything.
He also had a history of domestic abuse.
It was a very violent toward,
to hit her a bunch of times and it
could've just been that he went crazy
and just stabbed her,
but didn't all his friends that he was
doing blow all the time.
Didn't that guy that he jumped out the
window so he was selling them blow.
I don't know.
I do look it up.
I would have to.
Anyway.
So I'm just telling you sometimes these
things do exist.
Yes.
That's sad thing.
The managers.
Uh,
I dunno,
I know.
I'm not sure how I got there.
It's okay.
What was the lawyers?
The lawyers.
Fucking lawyers.
Fucking lawyer.
So the lawyer brought in this,
a guru as a guy that knows about drugs
and says,
Hey,
he was on drugs at a.
It kind of softens the blow of the
murder.
He didn't know what he's doing if he was
convicted,
if he was conducted.
So you never know,
look at,
come on.
So that was what they were going to
probably use on appeal.
Uh,
yeah.
You know,
lawyers in a sentence,
lawyers will bring in but bring them,
bringing them in.
So because we now trump won't say,
I apologize to John Mccain because if he
does doesn't everything else.
He said then come into light.
I don't know why you telling me that's a
good point.
But he didn't.
He never apologizes about anybody.
Remember.
So what did you say he did?
Now he's got lawyer.
Least fucking lawyers.
They tell him don't.
No,
no,
no.
Don't apologize now because if you do,
it's going to shed light on all the
other shit you said about mccain.
I don't think he listens.
I think trump does whatever the fuck he
wants.
I don't think he's going to listen to
any.
He's a 72 year old billionaire and I
don't think he listens to anybody.
I think he does whatever the fuck he
wants.
That's what I think.
That's the only thing that explains his
tweeting and all that crazy shit that he
says all the time.
Perhaps.
Yeah.
I mean that's just complete guessing.
No,
I know him.
I knew him.
Did you fuck here?
Does it feel weird that he's a
president?
Very.
He called.
Okay.
Amy over there worked for his wife for
seven years and then I got her
and I was in Maui sitting on my bed and
I get a phone call it song.
She was Jesus Christ is Donald.
She hands me the phone.
Did you save the Donald or just on know?
She said it's Donald.
She,
when we were free vodka.
I'm just kidding.
Malaria.
She worked for Melania in the family for
seven years.
Um,
I get the phone call,
I pick it up,
I'm sitting down and they said,
hey donald,
because we,
I've been down to Mar Lago and offered
money to do shows.
One offs for him and just stuff I've
been up,
been up to his little castle.
And um,
he calls me up and I said,
Donald,
you can't use dream on as for causes not
campaigns.
And he did anyway,
he did anyway.
And I had to sue him.
I got dino's whom send them a letter of
cease and desist.
So I've been through that shit.
So I kinda know where lawyers live.
You don't have this whole world's run by
lawyers.
And Donald's got 90 lawyers that are
telling them what the fuck.
Okay.
Maybe he's not listening.
Right?
But when everyone is saying,
if you just say John Mccain is a fucking
hero,
if,
if we don't see John Mccain is a hero,
then how do you expect any young people
to want to ever join the armed forces?
Because for everything they do in
bullets they take,
they're going to be laughed at by
president trump.
Right?
What the fuck are you saying Donald?
Well he said something crazy like,
but you see what I'm saying?
Soldiers that don't get caught thinks he
said but,
but they do.
War is war.
Who wants to.
Soldiers don't get caught because they
want to.
Exactly.
So I just tell you that,
you know,
he's not saying anything because he's
being told what to do.
Ah,
see,
I think he just does whatever the fuck
he wants.
And if the lawyers tell them,
Steven says,
you can't play dream on.
He's like,
fuck him.
He did.
He played in way.
So I had sent them a cease and desist.
Then he sends a letter and said,
what,
when I'm playing kid rock or something,
what did he found?
A better song goes,
I found a better song.
Actually.
I went with them freely.
That's his thing.
You know he likes insulting people and
you know what I see.
I see how that,
how people get off on his.
What it is is I get this isn't here
present for this time though?
I mean this is the time we were talking
before the show about people trying to
drag people down and social media and
there's so much hostility and people
looking to be angry and insult.
This is the time for that in a lot of
ways.
Unfortunately
I wonder if he's opening something good
pr.
He's opening Pandora's box for good or
is he opening Pandora's?
Our choice voice.
I think it's our choice,
but he's our president.
He's the president,
but I think we can respond to this bad
feeling that we have about those kinds
of actions in a positive way.
I think that's where there's an opening.
I think the opening is for people to
recognize that you're not going to live
forever.
You can't insult people into the grave
and feel good when you're dying.
It doesn't matter like what makes you
feel good right now.
If something makes you feel good to
constantly be knocking people down and
shitting on their grave that you'd
probably a terrible person.
Nobody wants to be a terrible person.
Least the majority of people don't.
So I think the majority of people are
gonna recognize that this path is a bad
one,
that it might feel good in the short
term to say,
fuck you,
I'm going to make America great again.
We're gonna fucking light the world on
fire.
But I think after awhile when the tide
goes in and the tide goes out,
people are gonna realize this is not the
way to go.
I hope.
I hope we're going to learn.
I think the world's getting better
overall.
I think there's terrible moments that
have always existed throughout human
history,
but I think overall,
if you look at the period of time we
live in now,
you know,
and Steven pinker wrote a great big book
about this and there's a lot of
evidence.
I read his book.
Yeah,
there's a lot of evidence that points to
that.
Every now and then I'll find somebody
on.
I'll preach something,
see something,
and I call my managers,
gave me his number,
called Steven up.
I'm from Boston.
I met him and had lunch.
He's great at what he call crab,
you know you know Boston?
Yes.
One of the best restaurants on planet.
The barking and crab fucking met him.
Had lunch with him and my marriage on
Macra.
What a fucking slamming guy.
Yeah,
he's a really is fucking smart as can
be.
Friendly.
This is the kind of people.
This is the.
I agree with you when it's time for
lifting up.
Yeah.
Well I think that's going to happen.
Is it really natural homeowners?
Well,
the more you know,
the more stupid shit goes on like this.
The more people are to recognize that
this is not.
It's not good.
Does it make people feel good and it's
not even good for conservatives,
but conservatives just like it because
it's their turn now and they're turned.
They got a bully on their side.
Just the boat is going to kick ass.
It's going to fucking do things the way
we want.
Yeah,
but even they're going to realize like,
this isn't the way you would admire
people.
This is the way to go.
There's,
there's A.
There's a possibility to be kind and
conservative at the same time.
These,
this is possible.
Yeah.
I think things will balance out that
well.
You know,
only time will tell.
Yeah.
Look,
overly optimistic at times,
so don't listen to me.
No,
that's the best way to be.
I think so.
You definitely don't want to go into the
whole.
That's what I'm saying.
Don't look at the music business at
hunter s Thompson.
Quote the music business.
You know when it comes to streaming,
you know,
you know this.
I love this quote.
It's a cruel and shallow money trench
along plastic hallway.
We're thieves and pimps run free and
good men die like dogs.
There's also a negative side.
I fucking hunter and I,
we were good friends for a bit.
I love that guy.
Yeah.
Yup.
I'm a giant fan.
Yeah,
he's a menu.
Yeah.
Let's wrap this up right here.
Dude.
You're the best.
I fucking hope he says we to do this
again.
I hope we opened up some doors here.
We did.
We had to open up some doors with me
about Ufo and shit.
I'm not going to a crystal ball.
I got to rethink my ship that it's
totally possible that Ufo is a real,
but be aware of people that tell you
they know the truth because people want
to know the truth.
So the people that come along and tell
you I know the truth,
too many of them are full of shit.
It's too easy.
It's an easy con game.
That's my thought on it.
Steven Thailand,
motherfucker.
Yeah,
respect.
Can I get A.
hmm?